Nein, nein.
Und damit herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio. Ich bin heute hier nur Gast, wie man vielleicht auch noch an der einen oder anderen düsseligen Nachfrage erfahren wird, die ich in dieser Sendung stelle. Ich bin Marco Seifert, vertrete heute Holger Klein. Keine Sorge, in Zukunft ist er beim Chaos Radio wieder dabei. Und richtig Sorge hat, glaube ich, auch Tim Pütlav, glaube ich, der jetzt Sorgen nicht.
Ich habe keine Sorgen.
Hast keine Sorgen.
Was soll dich für Sorgen haben?
Und du hast Gäste mitgebracht, die du vorstellen würdest, möglicherweise von dem einen das Mikrofon noch nicht geht, aber der kann dann ans andere mit rübergehen. Erstmal.
Genau, ich habe hier noch den Stefan mitgebracht.
Hallo.
Hallo Stefan. Du bist sozusagen der eine Experte. Und dann haben wir noch den Felix. Hallo und ja, die beiden kennen sich auch hervorragend aus in dem Thema, um das heute gehen soll.
Das Thema ist Web 2.0 Verheißung und Realität des neuen Web. Erklär es mir bitte.
Genau. Ja, worum es geht ist, dass wir hier nicht diese lustige Musik noch mit einspielen. Ja, ach, herrlich. Worum geht es? Das Web, also gemeint ist natürlich das World Wide Web, das was die meisten Leute benutzen im Internet, das hat jetzt einen langen Weg zurückgelegt. Und in den letzten Jahren gab es so viele neue Entwicklungen, sowohl in technischer Hinsicht als auch auf sozialer Ebene, also sowohl wie die Leute das benutzen, als auch wie es quasi für die Leute produziert wird, dass sich vor einigen Monaten, wie lange ist es her, halbes Jahr, was meint ihr? Ein Jahr schon hat sich halt dieser Begriff Web 2.0 entfaltet. Und der versucht halt so ein bisschen zusammenzufassen einfach die Tatsache, dass in so vielen Bereichen Quantensprünge erreicht wurden, dass es einfach Zeit ist für eine Re-Evaluation. Und nun ist das halt so ein bisschen das Basswirt, das in aller Munde ist und jeder hat so eine andere Vorstellung davon, was das nun genau ist. Und so eine ganz klare Definition, das können wir auch gleich vorwegnehmen, ist nicht möglich, weil das ist eine sehr diffuse Masse. Aber es gibt schon sehr viele klar erkennbare Trends, die dazu geführt haben, dass diese Neubenennung erforderlich war oder zumindest sinnvoll war. Und das wollen wir jetzt mal ein bisschen neabeleucht.
Das heißt, es wird im Chaosradio heute darum gehen, Bilanz zu ziehen, was in den letzten zehn Jahren passiert ist. Und noch spannender vielleicht nach vorne zu gucken, was wird sich in den nächsten 10, 20, 100 Jahren verändern.
Ja, vor allem auch so ein bisschen erst mal den Stand der Dinge, wie er jetzt gerade ist, weil jetzt ist halt schon sehr viel Neues da und das haben vielleicht die meisten Leute noch gar nicht so auf dem Zeiger. Und da wollen wir halt mal ein bisschen nachlegen.
Was könnte denn das konkret sein, was Neues da ist?
Ach, naja, da sollte man jetzt vielleicht auch wirklich erst mal...
Also ich versuch's konkret zu verstehen, was du meinst. Also wenn du von von zehn Jahren und was sich verändert hat, redest.
Also konkret meine ich halt, es gibt halt ganz neue Dienste im Web, die man benutzen kann und vor allem lassen sie sich halt ganz anders benutzen. Sind halt einfach in ihrer ganzen Funktionalität sehr viel einfacher geworden, sehr viel einfacher zu bedienen. Und das ist halt der sichtbare Teil. Es gibt natürlich auch noch einen unsichtbaren Teil, die Technologien dahinter, die sich ganz stark gewandelt haben, die das eben auch sehr viel einfacher machen. Um jetzt mal so ein bisschen noch allgemein zu bleiben in der Herangehensweise. Da sollte man erstmal ein bisschen beleuchten, woher das eigentlich alles kommt. Denn das Web ist ja an sich keine neue Geschichte. Wann ging es los? 1990, 1991 hat ein gewisser Herr Tim Berners-Lee dieses World Wide Web mal erfunden und er hatte vor allem eine konkrete Vision damit. Und die Vision war halt, dass man sowohl weltweit publizieren kann, das steckt ja in diesem Namen auch mit drin, aber eben nicht nur lesen teilnehmen, sondern vor allem auch schreiben teilnehmen. Also es ging halt wirklich um das Publishing, aber das Publishing sollte jetzt nicht einen wenigen vorbehalten, sondern die Ursprungsvision ist halt lesen und schreiben. Man kann also sowohl Inhalte leicht reinstellen, als auch die Inhalte leicht abrufen.
Das war die Idee am Anfang, die aber am Anfang ja zunächst nicht so richtig funktioniert hat, oder? Also am Anfang war es ja vor allem für die allermeisten, weil sie einfach sich mit der Technik noch nicht auskannten oder sie einfach nicht zu Hause hatten, ab und zu mal was, was sie lesen konnten, aber dass sie selber aktiv geworden sind, das ist ja erst in den letzten Jahren so gekommen, oder sehe ich da was falsch?
Ja, ganz am Anfang hat es schon funktioniert. Das Internet kommt ja ursprünglich aus einem universitären Umfeld und am Anfang war es so, wenn ich am Internet teilgenommen habe, dann konnte ich nicht einfach nur Konsument sein. Ich hatte da eine Kiste stehen, das war dann auch gleichzeitig mein Server. Server kennt man, das sind also die Kisten, auf der die eigentlichen Seiten rumliegen und die Transaktionen abgehen. Und am Anfang konnte man gar nicht anders daran teilnehmen. Und dann kamen die Kommerzialisierungen, die kamen dann eben zur Mitte der 90er und da wurde es dann quasi wieder asymmetrisch. Da wurden dann die meisten Nutzer zu Konsumenten degradiert, wenn man so will. Also ich hab mir mein Modem geholt und hab mich da eingewählt und dann konnte ich halt auf die Angebote zugreifen, die irgendwelche Firmen mir zur Verfügung gestellt haben, die halt für viel Geld Seiten produziert haben.
Genau, also für mich war es vielmehr so, dass ich früher hat man vermutlich Prospekte oder Ähnliches bekommen und dann am Anfang war das Internet so, das hat man dann im Netz gefunden und gelesen. So hatte ich es am Anfang verstanden, auch wenn die Idee dahinter eine andere war.
Genau.
Und inzwischen, und das ist eben auch ein Winkel, aus dem man das beleuchten kann, wird es halt so, dass die Leute wieder aktiver teilnehmen. Und das sind sicherlich, da gibt es verschiedene Gründe für, die wir dann sicherlich im Laufe der nächsten Stunden auch noch beleuchten können. Aber ein Trend, der sicherlich da ist, ist, dass die Leute aktiver daran teilnehmen. Also man sieht es an Fotos, die die Leute reinstellen, sogenannten Blogs, Webblogs. Da werden wir sicherlich auch noch drüber reden, die die Leute schreiben. Das heißt, aus Konsumenten werden plötzlich wieder auch Produzenten. Und das ist eigentlich das, wie das Web ursprünglich mal gedacht hat.
Und wie würdest du das einschätzen, wann das etwa war? Also, weil natürlich jetzt Webblogs sind seit, also, wie lange sind die jetzt ein großes Thema? Seit schon einer Weile, aber ich kann es gar nicht richtig zuordnen.
Also seit 30 Jahren?
Ja, also weil in der Zeit hat jede Tagestaltung ein paar Leute, die in den Senden.
Die eigentliche Schreiberevolution hat wirklich erst vor ein paar Jahren angefangen. Und meiner Meinung nach sind auch die Webblogs eigentlich das sichtbarste Zeichen davon. Ah, funktioniert jetzt dein Mikrofon?
Ja, ich glaube, mein Mikrofon funktioniert.
Stefan ist jetzt gleichberechtigt, darf jetzt auch schreiben im Chaosradio.
Was ihr alle nicht wissen zu hören, sind hier nur vier Leute, aber wir waren die ganze Zeit sechs. Vielen Dank übrigens. Also jetzt winken sie nochmal. Es wurde hier die ganze Zeit noch rumgebastelt, dass alle Mikrofone funktionieren und jetzt werden wir...
Wie man es ja auch gewohnt ist, aber normalerweise basteln ja immer wir und nicht der Studio Team.
Das Internet funktioniert auf jeden Fall vor der Funktechnik.
Ja, Webblogs, genau. Webblogs sind eigentlich das sichtbarste Zeichen dieser Umwälzung. Also bis dahin war ja eigentlich das Publizieren so ein total schwieriger Weg. Man musste irgendwelche HTML-Editoren benutzen, wenn man nicht in der Lage war, direkt die Sprache des Webbs auch selber in so einen Editor reinzuschreiben. Und auch wenn es natürlich immer mehr Leute gab, die da die Findigkeiten hatten, hatten die meisten Leute natürlich weder Zeit noch irgendwie Lust, sich jetzt allzu sehr mit der Technik zu beschäftigen, weil darum geht es ja eigentlich nicht. Man will einfach ein einfaches Werkzeug haben, wo man was reinschreibt und dann ist das eben da.
Genau, und am Anfang war es einfach zu kompliziert. Also es war bei mir immer das Gefühl, das verstehe ich sowieso nicht.
Ja, es ging halt einfach gar nicht. Es gab halt einfach überhaupt keine Systeme. Es gab halt einfach nur Webseiten und Firmen haben dann irgendwie sinnlos viel Geld auf irgendwelche Werbeagenturen geschmissen, die dann total unbrauchbaren Müll produziert haben. Und dann sind sie irgendwie alle komplett an den Agenturkosten dann auch pleite gegangen. Und dann kam aber die Kohle schon wieder vom nächsten Venture Kapitalisten. Diese ganze New Economy war ja eine Blase in jeder Hinsicht. Und gut, dass da mal einer reingestochen hat und dann ist das halt alles ein bisschen geplatzt. Und das hatten wir jetzt ja auch gerade in der Vorbereitung. Als wir hierher gefahren sind, haben wir uns das nochmal überlegt. Das war einfach wahrscheinlich das Beste, was dem Internet passieren konnte, war das Ende dieser New Economy, dieses ganzen Wahnsinns. Weil es sich einfach nur noch halb auf halb getürmt hat, ohne dass substanziell irgendwas Neues dazugekommen ist. Es war einfach ein reiner Basswortsägen, wo sehr wenig wirklich Substanzielles dabei war.
Ja, das ist sehr interessant, viele Themen, die man schon Ende der 90er gehört hat, die sich damals nicht realisiert haben, weil es an der Verbreitung gefehlt hat, am Verständnis der User, an den Bandbreiten, an den technischen Möglichkeiten. Die kommen jetzt wieder, unter anderem Vorzeichen mit weniger Geld, mit mehr Intelligenz. Und vor allem haben halt die User mittlerweile gelernt, wie sie mit dem Internet umgehen können und was sie von dem Internet auch erwarten und was sie wollen.
Also kann man sagen, sie haben das Internet für sich entdeckt. Vorher dachten sie, wie ihr vorhin schon gesagt habt, sie sind die Konsumenten, nur die Nutzer. Und jetzt sehen sie, man, das ist ja die Plattform, wo ich selber aktiv sein kann.
Genau, vorher war das Internet so ein bisschen wie Fernsehen. Man guckt halt hin und...
Das Internet nicht so sehr, das Web halt. Aber es gab ja schon Vorphänomene, zum Beispiel ICQ, Instant Messaging. Interessanterweise etwas, was die Geeks, die Technik-Spezialisten im Internet gar nicht so sehr auf dem Radar hatten am Anfang. Das hat sich ja in gesellschaftlichen Bereichen verbreitet, wo man erst mal gar nicht mit gerechnet hat, dass die auch schon am Internet teilnehmen. Aber das war natürlich jetzt keine Web-Technologie. Das war jetzt nicht so zum Anklicken. Aber das wurde eben auch schon benutzt. Chat und natürlich dann auch E-Mail natürlich, ganz klar als Killer-Applikation der ersten Stunde.
Könnt ihr noch einordnen, ihr, die von Anfang an dabei wart, wann das E-Mail seinen großen Durchbruch geschafft hat?
Das E-Mailen hat war eigentlich von Anfang an, also zu Beginn das Internet, das eigentliche Medium. Das hieß damals noch Usenet und das E-Mail Medium war das erste, was überhaupt als Applikation im Internet entwickelt wurde. Das war das erste, was man gesagt hat, ich hab da einen Rechner und ich hab da einen und die haben eine Netzwerkverbindung, also schick ich den Leuten, die da hocken, eine Nachricht zu. Zum Massenmedium wurde es erst, also es wurde ein bisschen zum Medium, als die ersten Privatkundenzugänge von CompuServe und so kamen und man nicht nur eine universitäre Adresse haben konnte. Zum Massenmedium wurde es dann richtig mit diesen ganzen Female Services wie Hotmail, wo man praktisch übers Web ganz einfach eine E-Mail-Adresse anlegen konnte. Vorher musste man in einer Firma sein oder bei einem bezahlten Dienst, Kunde sein, um so eine E-Mail-Adresse zu bekommen. Und seit es Hotmail gibt, seit man also einfach eine E-Mail-Adresse sich holen kann, hat sich das auch massiv verbreitet. Und heute hat jeder mehrere E-Mail-Accounts und E-Mail ist immer noch die meistgenutzte Funktion des Internet.
Entschuldigung, Tim läuft hier aufgeregt auf und ab, kann ich dir helfen?
Nein, ich muss gleich mal in den Nebenraum latschen, ich hab nämlich die Club-Mate stehen lassen.
Jetzt hab ich dich bloßgestellt, das hatte ich nicht. Du wolltest was sagen.
Ja, dieses E-Mail-Beispiel ist eigentlich ein sehr schönes wie das Internet jetzt im Endeffekt in der Gesellschaft angekommen ist. E-Mail war ja am Anfang auch in erster Linie ein technisches Protokoll. Inzwischen ist es so, dass das E-Mail, wenn ich nicht an E-Mail teilnehme, dann bin ich in gewisser Weise aus dem gesellschaftlichen Leben ausgeschlossen. Das heißt, es ist kein technisches Phänomen mehr. Das Internet ist mehr und mehr zu einem sozialen Phänomen geworden. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch an diesem Label Web 2.0 der entscheidende Aspekt. Es hat halt nichts mit Technik zu tun. Es hat was damit zu tun, dass das Internet in der Gesellschaft angekommen ist, dass die Leute es inzwischen benutzen können und es deswegen auch kreativer nutzen. Viele der Dinge sind ja schon ganz, ganz lange möglich, die jetzt gemacht werden.
Aber nur für Nerds, die da richtig schon drinstecken.
Genau, was wir vorhin schon hatten, dieses Homepage-Thema, das ist eine schöne Analogie zu den webbasierten E-Mail-Diensten. Die Technologie, die dahinter steckt, das sind dann sogenannte Content-Management-Systeme. Es war so, dass die Leute, die sich ihre Homepages gebastelt haben, die kennen wir ja alle, mit den Katzenbildern drauf. Das war ja so ein bisschen so eine Geschichte, okay, jetzt habe ich mal ein neues Hobby, jetzt baue ich Homepage. Und dann war es fertig und dann hat man es eigentlich auch nie wieder geupdatet und dann lagen sie da rum. Das war eben in dem Sinne auch Personal Publishing, aber man hat damit an keinem Diskurs teilgenommen. Und das, was die großen Firmen vorher schon konnten, nämlich Systeme zu haben, mit denen sie täglich ihre News reinstellen können, die sie für sehr viel, sehr viel Geld, Tim hat es sehr schön formuliert, bei irgendwelchen Werbeagenturen eingekauft haben. Diese Technik steht jetzt plötzlich jedem zur Verfügung. Das ist technisch nicht neu, sondern es ist jetzt einfach kostenlos und einfach zu bedienen. Und plötzlich, so wie E-Mail mal ein Privileg war der technisch versierte, ist jetzt plötzlich Publishing im Netz und eine Konversation teilnehmen und auch ganz banale Sachen, wie ich hab was in der Zeitung gelesen und möchte meine Meinung dazu äußern. Da hätte man früher nie deswegen seine Homepage angefasst. Plötzlich machen das die Leute. Und deswegen kommt ein ganz anderer sozialer Aspekt rein, weil die Leute miteinander diskutieren, wenn sie sich über Service geärgert haben, wenn sie irgendwie ein neues Produkt gekauft haben und sagen, das finde ich gut oder das finde ich schlecht.
Wir werden später in der Sendung ja auch noch nach vorne blicken. Was wird in den nächsten Jahren passieren? Aber jetzt sind wir kurz noch in der Vergangenheit. Habt ihr das so kommen sehen? Wenn wir beim E-Mailen bleiben am Anfang? Wann habt ihr geglaubt, dass es wirklich eine große Sache wird?
Also beim E-Mail war es mir klar, spätestens als meine Eltern E-Mail Adressen hatten, war mir klar, dass es eine große Sache wird.
Also vor zwei Monaten?
Das war so 1996. Auch relativ früh waren die dabei. Aber klar, ich hab die natürlich auch massiv gedrängt. Mit dem Personal Publishing war es für mich eigentlich... Also das erste, was ich im Internet, im Web gemacht hab, war mir den Browser anzugucken, den es damals gab, den Mosaik, am Universitätsrechenzentrum. Und das zweite, was ich gemacht hab, war, eine eigene Page zu bauen. Weil das der erste Reflex war. Ich kann das, muss das auch können. Ich will mich da auch darstellen. Und mir war immer klar, dass das Netz irgendwann mal auch wieder von den Usern zurückerobert wird. Weil das erste Netz, das universitäre Netz, das war ein Netz der User. Da waren nur Leute drin, die im Prinzip auch was reingeschrieben haben. Und es war mir klar, dass der Zeitpunkt irgendwann mal kommt. Und vor allem in den letzten paar Jahren haben sich die Technologien alle so vereinfacht und sind billig und verfügbar geworden, dass es sehr, sehr viele Services gab, die immer einfacher, immer neuere Möglichkeiten gebracht haben, den Leuten die Möglichkeit zu bieten, das zu tun. Auf eine schnelle, einfache Art. Und gleichzeitig, ein Blog ist ein sehr schönes Beispiel. Gleichzeitig wurde alles maßlos vereinfacht. Früher hat man eine Homepage gebaut mit animierten Bildchen drin und blinkenden Sachen und hat sich an der Technologie erfreut. Und heute ist ein Weblog ein ganz, ganz einfaches Tool, bei dem man einfach eine Nachricht reinschreibt und dann steht sie da drin. Das erleichtert natürlich auch den Zugang für jeden. Nicht nur was die Technologie angeht, sondern was die Art der Kommunikation angeht.
Du hast dir diesen Kopf damals überhaupt gemacht, ob das groß wird. Also jetzt reden wir darüber, was möglicherweise in 10 Jahren groß ist, werden wir später in der Sendung noch. Aber hast du dir damals den Kopf gemacht und wirklich gedacht, wir werden bald alle nur noch über E-Mails kommunizieren, bzw. es wird bald diese Webblogs geben, auf was immer man für einen Namen dafür im Kopf hatte.
Die Webblogs nicht, aber ich hab vorher mit Mailboxen was gemacht. Also die klassische Mode Kommunikation, die man damals gemacht hat. Das waren ja auch Netzwerke. Das war wirklich ein kleiner Teil von Leuten, die sich da die Zeit genommen haben und die Möglichkeiten hatten, das zu tun. Das Internet war auf einen Schlag sehr universell. Und ich hab sofort irgendwie für mich gemerkt, das ist das ganz große Ding. Und ich weiß noch, ich hab mich damals mit einer kleinen Firma selbstständig gemacht. Und einer unserer Kollegen ist 96 ausgestiegen und hat gesagt, naja, wer weiß mit dem Internet, ob das überhaupt was wird.
Ich kenn diese Gespräche auch. Ich hatte mit einem Kollegen, auch vor die ähnliche Zeit, die Diskussion, da sagte er, weißt du, früher wollten auf einmal alle Sprechfunkgeräte haben. Und alle dachten, ohne Sprechfunkgerät kommt man nicht mehr aus. Und das hat sich dann zerschlagen. Der war schon ein bisschen älter. Der meinte, so ist das heute mit dem Internet. Und in ein paar Jahren wird da keiner mehr von reden. Hat dann nicht wirklich recht gehabt.
Ich glaube, auch das Internet wird sich nicht durchsetzen.
Ich mag mich da fast gar nicht zu äußern. Ich war schon immer davon überzeugt, dass das alles digital wird.
Klingt so doof, wenn man das heute sagt.
Ja, jetzt kann man es nicht mehr beweisen. Aber für mich war es eigentlich von Anfang an eine Selbstverständlichkeit. Also eigentlich alles, wo ich auch nur absehen konnte, dass ich das demnächst sowieso nur noch auf eine digitale Art und Weise tun werde, habe ich dann aber auch sofort unterlassen. Also Musik zum Beispiel. Also ich habe schon extrem früh aufgehört, CDs zu kaufen. So, noch bevor wirklich das Internet mir dann auch die Alternative geboten hat. Aber ich wusste, das kommt eh. Und dann habe ich einfach mal eine Musikpause eingelegt, weil es war für mich dann schon nicht mehr zeitgemäß.
Also du wolltest nicht in eine veraltete Technik investieren? Das führt einfach natürlich egal um welches Medium, es geht immer dazu, dass man irgendwann eine Pause machen muss. Also ich meine, DVDs hast du wahrscheinlich auch nicht gekauft?
Doch, ich habe mir auch ein paar DVDs gekauft.
Weil da hast du dann den Fehler gemacht?
Naja, ich meine, es bricht jetzt ein bisschen die Argumentation, weil das ist natürlich, ja, das CD ist digital. Aber wir reden ja über Netzwerke und was diese Netzwerke irgendwie einem bereitstellen können. Aber für mich war einfach bei Musik schon sehr früh der Gedanke, dass ich da in so einen Laden gehen muss, um mir dann so eine komische Scheibe zu kaufen, wo auch nur eine Stunde Musik drauf ist, was für mich einfach alberne Länge ist. Das war für mich einfach nicht, das war für mich nicht zeitgemäß. Aber das ist ja auch egal, was ich da jetzt über Musik gedacht habe. Es war eigentlich von Anfang an dieser aufgeklärten Internetelite, die war eigentlich von Anfang an damit aufgesogen, mit diesem Gedanken, dass das das Universalnetz wird. Also ich glaube nicht, dass das in irgendeiner Form strittig war.
Also man hat sicherlich falsch gelegen im Laufe der Zeit, was einzelne Dienste angeht oder es ging Umwege und es gab Dinge, mit denen hat man so nicht gerechnet. Aber das, was Tim sagt, dass alle Inhalte irgendwann digital repräsentiert sind und dass alles frei fließen kann und frei verfügbar gemacht werden kann, also sprich die Digitalisierung und die Distribution übers Netz, sind sicherlich zwei Dinge, mit denen viele Leute schon lange gerechnet haben. Was es dann immer heißt, in welche Firma mache ich als nächstes auf und womit werde ich reich, da kann man dann mal gerne daneben liegen. Aber im Großen und Ganzen, ich glaube, das gibt so ein paar Dinge, auf die kann man bauen, genauso wie das Hardware und Bandbreite tendenziell billiger wird und leistungsfähiger.
Das ist ja auch eine Sendung, wo Hörer anrufen können. Worüber würdet ihr gerne mit denen diskutieren? Weil wir haben jetzt immer sehr rückwärtsgewandt geredet.
Wir sind unserem Kernthema noch nicht so richtig vorgestoßen. Aber was uns vor allem interessieren würde, ist, nicht wie nutzt ihr das Web, sondern nutzt ihr neue Dienste. Hat sich euer Kommunikationsverhalten nachhaltig da geändert? Wenn ihr da eine interessante Geschichte zu erzählen habt, dann würden wir das natürlich gerne hören. Wir würden aber auch gerne Anrufer haben, die jetzt in Technologien vielleicht selber mitentwickeln oder da eine Firma haben oder was auch immer, die dann in irgendeiner Form aktiv sind bei dieser neuen Klammer Web 2.0.
Ruf da so an und dann 0371-97-110, ich hab dich unterbrochen, Entschuldigung.
Eine Sache, die mich noch interessieren würde, ist habt ihr eine digitale Identität in irgendeiner Form, publiziert ihr im Netz und wenn ja wo, habt ihr einen Blog, seid ihr bei solchen Diensten wie MySpace etc. In welcher Form veröffentlicht ihr selbst?
Genau, benutzt ihr Flickr, benutzt ihr Delicious, podcastet ihr.
Und wenn ihr es nicht benutzt, warum benutzt ihr es nicht? Was sind eure Ängste oder Bedenken?
Könnt ihr von euch reden, was ihr benutzt bzw. was ihr nicht benutzt?
Ja, wir sind ja so Zwangspower-User, glaube ich. Man hat ja dann auch diesen Drang, dann auch wirklich alles einmal ausprobieren zu müssen. Kaum gibt es einen neuen Dienst, muss dann erstmal das Login gesichert werden, was man gerne überall hätte, damit man auch wüsst, wie es auf jeden Fall geht. Genau, das Cosmasyndrom nennen wir das jetzt mal. Man benutzt halt sehr viel und guckt eigentlich... Ich benutze dann immer gerne erst mal alles, wenn mir das überhaupt irgendein Wert, irgendwie wertvoll erscheint und schaue halt auch selber, inwieweit ich das, wie lange ich das selber benutze. Einfach, um es auch einschätzen zu können, ob das greift. Wie Felix schon gesagt hat, da trifft man es auch nicht immer. MySpace ist zum Beispiel jetzt in der jüngsten Zeit so ein Phänomen, was ein bisschen an mir vorbeigeflogen ist, was ja auch gerade eine extrem bekannte Website ist, die einem das Publizieren sehr vereinfacht und von daher von extrem vielen Leuten aufgegriffen werden. Aber das ganze soziale Phänomen, diese sozialen Netzwerke, wo sich Leute eben in neue Communities reinstürzen und dort eben im Kontext einer Website miteinander kommunizieren auf die Art und Weise, die diese Website eben ermöglicht, das sind so die spannenden Stellen. Es gibt natürlich noch einen etwas technischen Blick auf das Web 2.0 und das sollte man durchaus auch nochmal voranstellen, denn das ist jetzt nicht nur so, naja, jetzt haben wir 10 Jahre gewartet und jetzt kennen das alle und jetzt benutzen wir das anders, sondern das ist natürlich auch eine Frage der Werkzeuge. Und wenn man jetzt so zurückblickt, die ersten Zeiten, gab es ja so, erstmal gab es so die Pioniere, allen voran natürlich Netscape, die halt sich dann schnell einen großen Namen gemacht haben, die diese ganze New Economy-Welle ausgelöst haben und auf einmal waren alle total elektrisiert. Oh Gott, ein Webbrowser, ein Webbrowser. Diese Vision, dass man über das Web moderne Anwendungen benutzen kann und dass das in irgendeiner Form mein Betriebssystem ersetzen kann. Diese Idee war ja ganz früh draußen. Da sind auch verschiedene Leute auf bestimmte Methoden, bestimmte Arten und Weisen aufgesprungen. Also Sun hat schon seit Ewigkeiten, the Network is the Computer, in die Luft geschrien. Sie wollten dann halt, dass alle Leute Java benutzen. Das hat nicht wirklich so funktioniert, wie sie sich das vorgestellt haben. Aber vor allem hatte auch Netscape von Anfang an so diese Idee, dass der Webbrowser im Prinzip das Interface ist zu der Anwendung, die dann eben auf Servern läuft. Also heutzutage ist es ja eigentlich auch immer noch der Standard, will ich was mit meinem Computer machen, dann brauche ich ein Programm. Das Programm lade ich mir runter und dann macht das Programm halt auf meinem Computer alles. Die Idee von Netscape und den anderen frühen Webvisionären war halt genau andersrum. Nö, wir machen das alles auf dem Server und alles, was du brauchst, ist ein ganz einfaches User Interface und das soll ja auch alles ganz einfach sein. Und du hast den ganzen Trouble nicht, du musst nicht Festplattenkapazität bereitstellen, du musst dich nicht um das Speichern, um das Backup und so weiter und um die Software selber kümmern. Die Software kann auch sehr schnell weiterentwickelt werden natürlich auf dem Server, ohne dass man auf seinem eigenen Rechner irgendwas tun macht. Und soweit klang das natürlich auch erstmal super. Die haben dann versucht, das mit verschiedenen Produkten auch zu bedienen. Aber so richtig gezackt hat das halt noch nicht. Es gab ganz wenige Dienste, die da erfolgreich waren am Anfang, vor allem natürlich Webmail. Also Hotmail, der Name ist ja schon gefallen, die sind dann relativ früh losmarschiert, wurden dann später von Microsoft gekauft. Gab es noch einen anderen?
In Deutschland gibt es einige...
Web.de und Gmx, die sind natürlich in Deutschland sehr viel bekannter, weil es deutsche Unternehmen sind. Es gab noch irgendeinen außer Hotmail, der wie auch immer später zurück, ja dann auch Google nach mit Gmail. Also eigentlich hat heutzutage jeder Gesamtanbieter auf jeden Fall erstmal einen E-Mail-Dienst. Weil der E-Mail-Dienst natürlich, weil es eben auch der älteste Dienst im Internet ist, auch erstmal das Wichtigste ist. Dann kann man Bestätigungen hin und her schicken, dann kann man Nachrichten schicken und so. Jeder versteht vor allem auch E-Mail. Man muss heutzutage keinem mehr E-Mail erklären. Man muss vielleicht erklären, wie das Programm funktioniert, aber nicht, was E-Mail ist.
Ich hatte vorher damit gedroht, schlichte Fragen zu stellen. Jetzt kommt so eine. Wie viele E-Mail-Adressen hast du eigentlich?
Wie viele E-Mail-Adressen?
Wenn wir jetzt von allen Anbietern sprechen und wenn du dich da überall vielleicht angemeldet hast, wo erreicht man dich überall?
So schlimm ist das gar nicht.
Man braucht nur zwei, aber ich kenne Menschen, die haben locker 5, 6. Ich dachte, bei euch ist das völlig...
Man konsolidiert die dann nachher wieder auf einer Adresse und macht da den Spam-Filter rüber und holt sich nur noch die ab.
Ja, ich benutze eigentlich relativ wenige. Eigentlich gerne immer nur eine, aber für manche Zwecke hat man halt auch noch mal so ein bisschen andere Identität. Aber das ist eher eine technische Frage.
Was für Zwecke wäre das?
Na ja, sagen wir mal, wenn ich zum Beispiel bei Chaos Radio, wenn ihr uns ein E-Mail schicken wollt, könnt ihr auch mal ansagen, dann schickt ihr eine E-Mail an chaosradio.cdc.de. Und wenn ich da halt antworte, dann antworte ich halt auch mit der E-Mail-Adresse chaosradio.cdc.de, weil ich möchte ja, dass die Antwort dann auch wieder auf diesen Verteiler geht, damit eben auch die anderen Leute, die da mitlesen, ich beantworte das ja nicht alleine, das auch mitkriegen. Das ist halt eher so ein technischer Sachzweig an der Stelle. Es ist nicht wirklich so, dass das jetzt meine E-Mail-Adresse wäre. Aber gut, ich hab noch zwei, drei andere, aber das sind dann eigentlich eher so die E-Mails, die man normalerweise nicht benutzt.
Wir haben jetzt hier gleich die Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr. Danach wollen wir natürlich mit euch reden unter 033 71 97 110. Also unter anderem mit Elias und auch Matthias und mit euch, wenn ihr wollt und anruft.
Ihr Einsatzgebiet Berlin und Brandenburg. Ihr Auftrag Fritz Musik. Musik zum Tanzen.
Und im Radio Fritz vom RBB.
Eine Minute nach halb elf.
Nachrichten.
Mit Gerald Kötter-Einrich.
Sofort, sofort, sofort, sofort. Ich bin noch nicht ganz so weit. So, Nachrichten sprechen. Die Zahl rechtsextremer Gewalttaten in Deutschland ist im vergangenen Jahr deutlich angestiegen. Die Polizei registrierte 23 Prozent mehr Übergriffe als im Jahr zuvor. Das teilte der niedersächsische Innenminister Schünemann mit. Bundesweit begingen Rechtsradikale demnach 958 Gewalttaten. Die Zahl der Körperverletzungen mit rechtsextremen Hintergrund erhöhte sich sogar um 27 Prozent. Bundeskanzlerin Merkel und der russische Präsident Putin haben eine positive erste Bilanz ihrer Gespräche gezogen. Merkel sprach im sibirischen Tombsk von einer breit angelegten strategischen Kooperation. Hauptsächlich geht es bei dem Treffen um Wirtschafts- und Energiethemen. Im Verfahren um die Klage Berlins auf Milliardenhilfe des Bundes hat sich Finanzsenator Sarrazin zu weiteren Sparanstrengungen bereit erklärt. Berlin werde alle denkbaren Auflagen erfüllen, sagte Sarrazin vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht in Karlsruhe. Dort prüfen die Richter, ob das hochverschuldete Land Anspruch auf Sanierungshilfe des Bundes hat. In Brandenburg ist erstmals ein Storch an der Vogelgrippe verendet. Das teilt ein Sprecher des Agrarministeriums in Potsdam mit. Das Friedrich-Loeffler-Institut für Tiergesundheit hatte den Erreger H5N1 bei einem Weißstorch festgestellt. Ob es sich um die gefährliche Asiavariante des Virus handelt, steht noch nicht fest. Der Kadaver des Tieres war im Landkreis Märkisch-Oderland gefunden worden. Das Wetter. Heute Nacht sind Schauer und Gewitter möglich. Die Temperaturen sinken auf 11 bis 8 Grad. Und morgen gibt es im Westen Brandenburgs weiterhin Schauer. Richtung Oder und Neiße bleibt es trocken. Die Temperaturen steigen auf 15 bis 20 Grad. Der Verkehr fritze mit drei Meldungen. A12 Berliner Ring Richtung Frankfurt Oder. Stau zwischen Storkow und Fürstenwalde West. A13 Dresden Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz. Vorsicht bitte zwischen Schwarzheide und Groß Reichen. Hier liegen Gegenstände auf der Fahrbahn. Und Stadtautobahn Berlin A100, welligen Richtung Wilmersdorf. Die Autobahn ist zwischen Charlottenburg und Hohenzollern am Wegen in Standhaltungsarbeiten bis 5 Uhr früh gesperrt. Ansonsten keine aktuellen Meldungen. Gute Fahrt.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2, dann Fritz in Spremberg.
Ihr hört das Chaos Radio auf Ritz um kurz nach halb elf zu Gast hier heute. Marco Seifert muss man fast sagen, weil sonst ist das ja mit Holger Klein. Er konnte heute nicht. Nächstes Mal natürlich wieder beim Chaos Radio dabei. Und ich bin nicht alleine, sondern hier sind natürlich auch Tim Prydlove, Felix Petersen und Stefan Kellner. Ich hoffe, ich hab jetzt hier alles richtig gemacht und man kann euch hören. Die haben ja heute ein bisschen Mikrofontrouble. Und ihr könnt anrufen unter 033 171 97 110. Und der erste Anrufer ist Elias, 15 Jahre alt, aus Potsdam. Hallo Elias.
Hallo.
Ja, ich wollte was sagen zu Webseiten und auch zur Homepage. Und zwar habe ich selber auch welche, mach das auch als Hobby. Und finde das eigentlich nicht so schön, dass es ja zu viele Programme gibt, die das so vereinfachen. Also, dass man nur den Text schreibt und das Programm macht, ist alles fertig und schön, weil ich mach das auch gern für andere Leute. Und dann wird natürlich so die Arbeit weggenommen und fast jeder hat eine Webseite irgendwo.
Die brauchen dich nicht mehr und das ärgert dich?
Ja auch. Und das zweite ist dieser ganze Spam. Also es gibt so viele unnütze Webseiten, auch private Homepage über Katzen, wie schon gesagt wurde. Und dann sind erstens natürlich die Adressen weg. Also dann kriegt man keine ordentliche Adresse mehr. Und zweitens auch von diesen Suchmaschinen sind dann einfach so überfüllt von Webseiten, die man nicht braucht und das nervt natürlich.
Ja gut, aber das muss ja alles nicht benutzen. Das kann dir ja eigentlich egal sein. Wenn für die anderen Leute das besser und einfacher ist, damit zu posten, dann soll man diese doch lassen.
Ich finde nur, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel eine Webadresse brauche, dann ist es wesentlich schwerer, die zu bekommen, weil es einfach so viel belegt sind. Und ich glaube, das kommt auch daher, dass es einfach heutzutage so einfach ist, so etwas zu bekommen und so komplett alles fertig ist.
Ja, musst du ja lustigere Adressen einfallen lassen. Wie wäre es mit ich mag keine Katzen.de? Gibt es bestimmt noch, oder? Oder vielleicht auch nicht, was weiß ich. Okay, und Web 2.0 sagt dir nichts? Web 2.0 sagt dir nichts? Okay, dann musst du noch ein bisschen weiter zuhören.
Elias, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Ja, ich glaube, wir müssen noch ein bisschen mal hier auf den Hintergrund eingehen und ich würde ganz gerne mal die Technik mehr beleuchten, weil jetzt haben wir so ein bisschen den großen Bogen gespannt und das Ganze erstmal sozial aufgeklappt. Das ist natürlich offensichtlich. Aber es gibt auch ein paar technische Meilensteine, die recht wichtig sind, um zu verstehen, warum jetzt eigentlich alle so aufgeregt sind. Da ist ja zunächst einmal die Grundlage des Internets, war halt HTML und das ist am Anfang doch ordentlich vergewaltigt worden. Wenn man sich mal so durch das Web gewühlt hat als Techniker, da konnte einem eigentlich nur der kalte Schauber bei den Rücken laufen, weil es war halt alles sehr mies spezialisiert, spezifiziert. Jeder hat es, obwohl es dann selbst wenn es spezifiziert war, wurde es halt einfach nicht so benutzt, wie es in der Spezifikation stand. Und es gab einfach einen extremen Wildwuchs und vor allem auch extreme Inkompatibilität. Man hat das ja alles noch im Sinn. This side optimized for Internet Explorer. Ja, also wo dann auch Gestalter dazu übergegangen sind, zu sagen, ich will jetzt aber, dass das so und so aussieht und das geht halt nur mit dem Internet Explorer und dann quasi so einen Zwang auf den Benutzer gelegt hat, dass er doch jetzt bitte das benutzen soll, obwohl er unter Umständen auf einem Betriebssystem arbeitet, wo es diesen Internet Explorer gar nicht gibt. Beziehungsweise wo es ihn vielleicht gibt, aber anders funktioniert, weil es auch nicht dasselbe Produkt ist. Also da war halt auch noch sehr viel Unkenntnis auf beiden Seiten. Also weder wussten die Leute, mit was sie da bombardiert werden, noch wussten die Leute, die irgendwelche Inhalte anbieten, mit welchen Standards sie jetzt eigentlich operieren sollten. Es war extremer, extremes Durcheinander und die Benutzbarkeit von Webseiten hat einfach extrem gelitten. So kann man das, glaube ich, mal zusammenfassen. Mittlerweile hat sich das halt entspannt. Es gibt so ein paar Standards, die sich einfach durchgesetzt haben. Da muss man auch sagen, da hat die Open Source Bewegung einen ganz großen Anteil dran gehabt durch den Browser. Firefox ist eine extreme Umdenkung in den Gang gekommen, weil auf einmal dieser Omni-Anspruch von Internet Explorer, wir sind das Internet, der griff halt nicht mehr. Zwar ist der Firefox weltweit, glaube ich, ungefähr bei 10% Verbreitung, wobei in Europa sind es, glaube ich, 20%, in Deutschland sind es sogar 30%, aber vor allem sind eben auch diese ganzen webaffinen Leute, also alle die Leute, die auch wirklich die modernen Anwendungen machen, sind relativ schnell gewechselt und haben sich das zumindest angeguckt. Und das Ergebnis war, dass man auf einmal mit diesen ganzen Standards, die vorher nur im Buch standen, auf einmal auch arbeiten konnte. Also auf einmal fing das Web auch so an zu funktionieren, wie das eigentlich mal gedacht war. Die ganzen Elemente taten das, was man tun wollte. Und das ist ein zweiter wichtiger Schritt, die Skriptbarkeit des Systems wurde halt immer besser. Ja, das ist, lustigerweise hat ja, lustigerweise hat das ja Microsoft sogar eingeleitet, muss man ehrlich sagen.
Ja, ich denke, einer Aspekt ist auch noch ganz wichtig, ist ja nicht nur die Technik, die sich vereinheitlicht hat und mehr standardisiert hat und es einfacher macht, Dinge zu entwickeln, sondern das ist auch die Entwicklung, wie die User mit dem Netz umgehen. Am Anfang hat man halt gedacht, okay, wir haben jetzt ein neues Medium für unseren Prospekt. Und dann hat man halt eine Webseite gemacht, die aussah wie der Prospekt und hat gesagt, guck mal, jetzt ist unser Prospekt im Internet.
Wofür HTML nie gedacht war.
Wofür diese Sprache nie gedacht war. Die Sprache war, wenn man es überhaupt Sprache nennen darf, die Formatierungssprache war dafür entwickelt worden, dass Wissenschaftler ihre Texte ordentlich formatieren können. Und sonst gar nichts. Es war nicht unbedingt vom Aussehen, sondern vom Inhalt her. Also wie ist das Dokument strukturiert und wo fängt die Überschrift an und wo hört sie auf?
Und deswegen war es so kompliziert.
Nee, es war eigentlich sehr einfach, solche Dokumente zu erstellen.
Solche Dokumente, aber wenn man dann was anderes machen wollte, war das kompliziert, weil es dafür nie gedacht war.
Genau, weil es dafür nie gedacht war. Und dann wurde es halt immer wieder erweitert. Gerade die verschiedenen Browser-Hersteller, Netscape und Microsoft, haben immer neue Features eingeführt. Und da hat man halt Elemente genommen, die zum Beispiel gedacht waren für eine Tabelle von Daten, die hat man dann nachher genommen, um das Layout von einer Seite zu beeinflussen. Andererseits ist es aber auch so, dass man mittlerweile auch gelernt hat, was die Menschen im Internet wollen und wie sie mit den Websites umgehen. Und das sieht man ja ganz, ganz deutlich bei so Websites wie Google. Einfacher geht es ja nicht. Und die Website hat sich seit sie gelauncht wurde, praktisch nicht verändert. Also wenn ich auf Google gehe, dann sehe ich immer noch dieses eine Eingabefeld und ein Button.
Was übrigens auch ein Grund für den Erfolg von Google war, weil damals hieß der Contender Alter Vista. Das war eigentlich das, was damals alle benutzt haben. Und bei Alter Vista sind sie den anderen Weg gegangen. Die dachten so, ah ja, super, jetzt Portale sind dann auf den nächsten Hype aufgesprungen.
Haben ein Feature.
Haben aus ihrer super schlichten Seite, die mal genauso daher kam wie Google, so ein Portalmonstrum gemacht. Und das hat die Leute natürlich dann noch mal sehr viel schneller zu Google gefegt. Die natürlich auch noch technisch besser waren, aber das war auf jeden Fall auch ein Grund.
Ein Extrembeispiel sind diese ganzen, als Macromedia Flash rauskam, das sind diese großen, bildschirmfüllenden Animationen, die es irgendwann mal ab 97, 98 gab, hat jedes Unternehmen praktisch als einen kleinen Trailer vor die Website gestellt, den man erst mal wegklicken musste.
Genau, man konnte es zum Teil auch gar nicht skippen, oder?
Das war ganz am Anfang.
Das ist ja ganz furchtbar. Dann hast du da ewig gesessen und gesagt, okay, die Seite ist nicht meine.
Das gibt es aber heute auch noch teilweise. Also zum einen die technische Standardisierung und zum anderen auch die Erfahrung, dass man heutzutage sagt, wir lassen viel von dem Schnickschnack weg, weil die Leute wollen Informationen, die wollen lesen und sie wollen sich leicht zurechtfinden, führen jetzt dazu, denke ich, dass man heute halt Dinge anders angeht. Und interessanterweise führt das nicht nur dazu, dass die Websites besser werden, sondern dass sie auch weniger kosten. Wenn man sich überlegt, was man nicht ist. Dort kommt für ein kleines Portal hingelegt hat, haben die Hunderttausende von dem halt damals verblasen. Heute kann man das mit Open Source Software und drei guten Entwicklern in drei Wochen machen. Also das ist alles sehr viel schneller und einfacher geworden.
Aber um dann wieder den Bogen zurück, nachdem quasi jetzt diese Phase der Einfachheit und der Bescheidenheit kam, ist jetzt eben dann mit der Standardisierung und das, was Temi eben angesprochen hat, auch mit dem Firefox, wird es halt plötzlich wieder möglich, diese Spielereien, die es ja eigentlich schon immer gab, die aber sehr inkompatibel waren und die man eben als das genau genutzt hat, als Spielereien, also kleine Animationen und Geschichtchen, die kann man ja auch sehr sinnvoll verwenden. Man kann sie nämlich dazu benutzen, dass eine Website sehr viel mehr ist als nur zur Darstellung von Informationen, sondern dass eine Website sich auch zunehmend so verhalten kann, wenn man es denn richtig programmiert, wie eine Applikation, die man auf seinem normalen Rechner laufen hat. Also Google hat da beispielsweise, obwohl sie ein sehr, sehr einfaches Interface für ihre Suche haben, haben sie dann bei dem nächsten sehr erfolgreichen Dienst, den sie rausgebracht haben, bei Google Mail, sind sie nämlich dazu übergegangen, zu sagen, naja, wie benutzen die Leute eigentlich ihr E-Mail-Programm lokal? Und es ist selbst Leute, die Webmail haben, wenn die jetzt bei GMX sind, werden einem zustimmen, dass sie doch lieber noch ihr Programm auf dem Rechner benutzen. Google hat sich dieses Programm angeguckt und hat gesagt, was kann das eigentlich, was so eine Webmail nicht kann? Und hat dann quasi mit technischen Möglichkeiten, also im Endeffekt wieder mit JavaScript und einer anderen Technologie namens Ajax, auf die wir sicherlich gleich nochmal ein bisschen ausführlicher kommen, diese Nutzungserfahrung, die man eigentlich nur bei seinem normalen E-Mail-Programm hat nachgebaut, also beispielsweise, dass Dinge direkt ausklappen, ohne dass die Seite neu lädt. Man hat das Ganze dann wieder sehr viel benutzbarer gemacht. Und das ist natürlich ein Vorteil dieser Standardisierung, dass Web-Sites jetzt plötzlich mehr können, ohne dass man sie dazu vergewaltigen muss.
Das ist ein gutes Beispiel, hier können wir vielleicht mal das eine oder andere technische Basswirt mal fallen lassen, man spricht ja auch ganz gerne von Widgets. Das sind so kleine Benutzer-Interface-Elemente, die dann eben auch langsam in Webseiten auftauchten, wie man das halt vom normalen Computer Benutzung her kennt. Man kennt halt Buttons, gut, das gab es halt von Anfang an, aber halt so was, dieses Dreieckbeispiel, so ich klappe mir Informationen auf, so eine hierarchische Struktur, sowas war halt nicht so ohne Weiteres zu machen, weil im Prinzip jeder Klick immer bedeutete in einer Webseite, jeder Klick geht sofort zum Server und wenn ich was Neues sehen will, dann muss der Server mir das berechnen, wieder schicken und mit langsamen Leitungen hat er einfach ewig gedauert. Und dadurch, dass man jetzt in der Lage war, dieses Scripting, diese Logik wieder in den Browser zurück zu verlegen, kann man halt bestimmte Entscheidungen noch auf dem Computer machen, ohne jetzt das langsame Netz an der Stelle zu benutzen. Und das führt eben jetzt zu einer Snappiness in den User-Interfaces, die... Zu einer was, Entschuldigung? Ja, eine Snappiness, also es ist... Es flutscht. Es flutscht, genau, schöner hätte ich es jetzt nicht formulieren können. Es geht halt schnell. Es ist halt nicht eine lange Datenübertragung damit verbunden, sondern ich kann es halt sofort machen. Und ein Datenaustausch mit dem Server findet eben erst dann statt, wenn es wirklich nötig ist. Es gibt da ein schönes Ober-Buzzword, was in aller Munde ist. Das nennt sich Ajax, A-J-A-X, also Ajax, so wie das Scheuer-Pulver. Und der Begriff wurde im letzten Jahr halt aufgebracht und hat im Prinzip so mal ein paar Technologien zusammengefasst. Also im Prinzip heißt das...
Genau.
Das andere ist AHA.
Das gibt's auch.
Asynchrones HTML and...
Das wird sich nicht durchsetzen. Das wird sich nicht durchsetzen. Nein, also asynchronous JavaScript mit XML. JavaScript ist halt diese Scriptsprache, die im Browser läuft. Das ist etwas, was man früher ganz gerne auch mal ausgeschaltet hat, weil es eigentlich immer nur bedeutet hat, dass eben das neueste Experiment des Web Designers jetzt auch noch einen genervt hat. Dazu kamen am Anfang vor allem auch noch zahlreiche Sicherheitsprobleme, die durch die frühen Implementierungen von JavaScript so ausgelöst wurden. Aber die Zeiten sind ja halt jetzt vorbei. Ich sage nicht, dass es nicht nach wie vor auch noch ein Sicherheitsproblem sein kann, aber das gilt halt nicht nur für JavaScript, das gilt eben auch für jede andere Komponente, die in dem Browser läuft. Aber im Prinzip ist zu dem Statischen, ich beschreibe wie der Inhalt deiner Seite ist, HTML, ist noch das Dynamische. Ich erlaube deinem Browser während dieser Inhalt angezeigt wird, dass man das eben auch noch dynamisch umsortiert, rearrangiert, wie auch immer, irgendetwas tut und vor allem auch so ein kleines Häppchen mit dem Server zu kommunizieren. Und das kann man eben mit der Programmiersprache JavaScript machen. Und diese Kombination und das dritte ist dann eben XML, was ja im Prinzip so der, das ist so der Syntax Standard für komplexe Dokumente im Web. Also alles, was man heute eigentlich im Web hin und her schickt zwischen dem Programm, ist im Prinzip in XML, kann man mal so festhalten. Das ist nichts, was man sich jetzt genauer anschauen muss. Im Prinzip einfach nur ein hierarchisches Datenformat, wo man alles reinpacken kann. Und man schickt halt dieses XML hin und her. Das Skript, was halt in dem Browser mit läuft, tut das. Und das HTML zeigt, wie seit Tag 1 zeigt das eben einfach im Browser an. Und ja, jetzt war das schön verpackt mit diesem Begriff AJAX. Ah super, wir haben ja jetzt AJAX. Und dadurch hat sich einfach ein komplett neues Programmierungsmodell durchsetzen können, was an sich jetzt so vom Modell her nicht neu war, aber es war halt neu, dass es das jetzt im Browser gibt. Und dadurch hat man jetzt intelligente Webseiten, würde ich das mal nennen.
Ja, es ist im Endeffekt die Verbindung, wie man so schon sagt, das Beste aus beiden Welten, was ja immer gut war an Web. Es war von überall verfügbar. Ich kann also in meinem Internetcafé auf mein Webmail zugreifen. Auf der anderen Seite, was gut war an Programmen ist, sie flutschten, sie waren einfach zu bedienen. Und es war halt nicht so, nicht jedes Mal wenn ich einen Button drücke, klickt die Webseite, lädt die Webseite neu. Und mit AJAX ist es jetzt quasi möglich zu sagen, ich kann beides haben. Ich kann also eine Webseite haben, die sich bedient wie ein Programm und die im Hintergrund die Sachen lädt. Man kennt das ja von so Bestellprozessen, also ein Formular ausfüllen, dann lädt die Seite neu, dann kriegt man zum Beispiel ein sehr gutes Beispiel, was viele Leute sicherlich ärgert. Sie haben vergessen, das und das einzugeben. Gut, dann gebe ich das ein, klicke ich auf abschicken, kommt wieder was zurück, so von wegen, oh Gott, jetzt hier wieder sechs Stellen im Passwort. Das kann ich zum Beispiel mit AJAX sehr schön abfangen. Das muss man sich so vorstellen, ich fülle das Formular aus und während ich dieses Formularfeld ausfülle und ich zum nächsten gehe, sagt er mir quasi, die E-Mail-Adresse oder der Username ist schon vergeben. Das heißt, ich muss es tatsächlich nur einmal abschicken. Und das ist schon von der Benutzung her eine extreme Erleichterung. Und das ist nur der Anfang. Aber so muss man sich das halt vorstellen. Die Website rüdelt im Hintergrund und lädt nicht dauernd neu, um einem zu sagen, das durftest du jetzt gar nicht tun.
Das Schöne ist bei der Geschichte auch, dass es auch zum Programmieren einfacher sein kann. So neu ist die Technologie ja nicht. Die Elemente dieser Technologie gibt es schon seit ein paar Jahren. Aber erst im letzten Jahr haben die Leute angefangen, wahrscheinlich, weil es diesen Begriff gab, oder was weiß ich, ist ja oft so, wenn man für irgendetwas einen Namen hat, dann macht man was damit.
Das war total wichtig, dass es mal jemand Ajax genannt hat. Irgendso ein Blogger, der hat gesagt, ich nenne das jetzt mal Ajax. Das fanden dann alle so toll. Mit Web 2.0 ist es eigentlich genauso, dass es nur auf dem größeren ist.
Und seitdem kann auch der Projektmitgliederagentur sagen, mach das doch mal mit Ajax. Im Vorjahr war das halt zu kompliziert.
Was ich sagen wollte, dadurch, dass es da ein bisschen Aufregung darüber gab, sind jetzt auch viele Frameworks, also Entwicklungsumgebungen entstanden, mit denen man sehr einfach solche Applikationen bauen kann. Und wenn man das richtig macht und sich ein bisschen drauf einlässt, kann man auch schneller und einfacher Sachen programmieren. Das ist also nicht nur für den User einfacher zu benutzen, sondern auch einfacher in der Programmerstellung. Wenn man sich überlegt, wo die alte Technologie, die man vorher benutzt hat, also dass man immer was in den Server schickt und dann wieder eine komplette Seite zurückbekommt, die ist im Prinzip genauso alt wie das Web. Also da hat sich in den letzten 15 Jahren relativ wenig getan und es war jetzt echt mal Zeit, dass da mal wieder was passiert.
Ja, der Chat ist natürlich skeptisch hier, wenn wir sowas sagen wie intelligente Webseiten, dann kriegt man dann mal gleich wieder eins auf den Deckel. Und das ist auch eine sehr berechtigte Sichtweise, denn bei aller Euphorie darf man auch nicht vergessen, dass natürlich umso komplexer das alles wird, auch wenn es an sich noch einfach ist, aber es nimmt halt an Komplexität zu, auch sich ganz neue Sicherheitsfragen stellen. Dieses Web 2.0 in seiner ganzen Selbstdarstellung lebt vor allem von den Communities. Am Anfang gab es ja auch schon mal im Web den Trend, solche Communities aufzubauen, also Leute unter einem Namen in irgendeiner Form im Internet zusammenzufassen und dort sich austauschen zu lassen. Mittlerweile ist das ja der helle Wahnsinn. Man ist ja nicht mehr in einer, sondern man ist ja eigentlich schon fast in allen. Die Leute haben eine unglaubliche Bereitschaft entwickelt, ihre Daten im Netz zu hinterlassen. Und die ganzen Dienste sind natürlich jetzt auch darauf ausgelegt, dass man halt alles auf dem Server speichert, weil es soll ja bei meinem eigenen Computer einfacher werden. Angenommen, ich entscheide mich jetzt für den Google Lifestyle. Dann habe ich eigentlich überhaupt keinen eigenen Computer mehr, sondern ich benutze halt irgendwie Gmail und dann gibt es jetzt auch noch den Kalender, wo ich meine ganzen Termine automatisch aufpoppen lassen kann. Demnächst werde ich da sicherlich auch meine Textverarbeitungsdokumente schön kompatibel mit Word im Browser schreiben können, mit ausreichendem Komfort. Visioniere ich jetzt mal so vor mich hin, dieses Produkt. Ja, sie haben gerade Writely gekauft. Ich denke, das wird in die Richtung gehen. Ich habe aber mit dem Writely noch nicht gearbeitet, deswegen kann ich da nicht wirklich was zu sagen, wie gut sich das bedienen lässt. Aber das ist jetzt schon absehbar. Die Komplexität dieser neuen Technologien reicht aus, um eben auch solche klassischen Programme schon abzubilden. Das heißt, ich speichere dann auch schon gar nichts mehr auf meinem Computer, weil ich habe unter Umständen auch gar keinen. Meine Texte sind da, meine Daten sind da. Irgendwann wird auch noch meine Musik und meine Videos dort zentral gespeichert sein.
Aber da gehört doch dann viel Vertrauen dazu. Absolut, ja. Wenn ich es nicht mehr zu Hause im Schrank habe oder wo auch immer.
Das ist das, was ich meine. Das ist halt, nennen wir es Sicherheit, nennen wir es Vertrauen. Auf jeden Fall ändert sich da was in diesen Besitzverhältnissen. Auf einmal besitzt man die Dinge nicht mehr so, sondern es hängt im Prinzip alles nur noch an einem Passwort. Und hat man das dann vergessen, dann geht es halt los.
Ja, und man gibt irgendjemanden, dem man nicht kennt, eine unglaubliche Macht. Der hat ja so viele Daten bei sich und kann die mit einem Knopfdruck eigentlich für sich behalten und uns nie wieder ranlassen.
Auf der einen Seite ist es ja so, dass man dadurch, dass man seine Daten irgendwo anders ablegt, oft eine größere Sicherheit hat. Ich habe ja selber kein so ein gutes Backup oder ich brenne es nicht jeden Tag auf CD. Wenn ich es dort habe, weiß ich, das ist eine tolle Firma. Also ich denke, man kann es ein bisschen vergleichen mit der Bank. Es gab ja auch irgendwann mal den Punkt, wo man gesagt hat, ich bringe mein Geld zur Bank. Und so bringe ich meine Daten zu Google. Und ich habe halt ein verhältnismäßig mittelmäßiges Vertrauen zu meiner Bank.
Mehr?
Aber mehr als zu Google?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Das ist aber echt natürlich ein sehr, sehr schönes Bild. Aber wenn ich irgendwann Sorge hatte, dass die Bank es nicht mehr lange macht, dann sind alle hingerannt und haben ihr Geld wieder abgeholt.
Ich weiß nicht, was bei Google passiert, wenn alle User morgen ihre E-Mail runterlassen.
Wenn alle Leute ihr Geld von der Bank holen, bricht die Bank zusammen. Wenn die Leute ihre Daten von Google holen, kommt eine freie Serverkapazität.
Ich glaube, dass die Server zusammenbrechen. Der schwarze Datenfreitag. Das ist eine schwierige Frage. Wir fragen uns das auch oft. Wir benutzen beide Google Mail in verschiedener Form. Ich hab da alles drin und man lässt es dort ja auch drin. Man hat ja mehr oder weniger unbegrenzt viel Speicherplatz. Und ich sag ja auch, search down sort und frag einen, willst du die E-Mail wegschmeißen? Brauchst du dein Mülleimer nicht leer zu machen? Wir haben ja so viel Speicherplatz. Ich frag mich da auch oft, wie könnte mein komplettes Leben der letzten anderthalb Jahre nachvollziehen? Das macht einen dann schon ein bisschen kritisch.
Inklusive aller Firmen Mails.
Ja, aller Firmen Mails und allem Möglichen, was ich so gemacht hab. Das ist schon sehr, sehr schwierig. Im Moment vertraue ich denen noch, aber wer weiß, das kann sich auch ändern. Ich hätte jetzt wirklich Hemmungen. Für mich ist es ein großer Faktor, der mein Leben vereinfacht. Ich hab verschiedene Computer und bin in verschiedenen Orten. Ich muss nicht immer organisieren, wo ich meine Mail herkriege. Ich muss keinen Backup machen. Das überwiegt im Moment der Convenience-Faktor. Aber auf Dauer wird ich mir auch überlegen, meine Textverarbeitung im Web zu machen. Da müsste ich schon jemanden haben, dem ich so vertrauen kann wie einer Bank.
Dieses neue Servermodell erlaubt nicht mal, dass man das alles verschlüsselt. Weil natürlich das System davon ausgeht, dass man mit diesen Daten umgehen kann. Da liegt natürlich auch ein Interesse daran. Google hat von Anfang an auch gesagt, wir machen hier Gmail, das ist irgendwie kostenlos. Aber wir gucken auch mal rein in eure E-Mails. Aber nicht im Sinne von, da setzt sich jemand hin und liest die sich durch und findet sie lustig oder kompromittierend oder sonst irgendwas. Sondern natürlich schauen da die Suchmaschinenfunktionen rein, damit sie dann eben passend zu dem Inhalt, die passende Werbung dazu schalten können, während man halt mit dem E-Mail arbeitet. Und das ist halt so der Ansatz, bei dem die wollen natürlich auch schon wissen, um welche Daten es geht. Und natürlich gewinnen die daraus auch sehr viele Sekundärinformationen, die für ihr Business wichtig sind. Weil man kann dadurch Trends ableiten, worüber redet die Welt? Google weiß das. Sie wissen es natürlich nur aus dem Anteil, der bei Google die Daten speichert. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele User es gibt, hat Google mal was gesagt, wie viele Gmail-User sie haben, aber wahrscheinlich extrem viele. Und das ist natürlich auch ein Wert. Und die Bank, die du gerade da, die du Felix angesprochen hast, die Deutsche Bank, die unterliegt nun zumindest auf dem deutschen Datenschutzrecht, das ist auch jetzt nicht das Beste, was man sich vorstellen kann, aber doch zumindest eine ganz andere Situation darstellt als in den USA. Also man hat seine Daten in einem Land, das eigentlich juristisch für einen gar nicht zuständig ist. Und auch das ist eins dieser Risiken, die mit diesen neuen Modellen daherkommt.
Aber ich krieg's richtig mit ihr. Sorgt euch alle darum, aber Konsequenzen sieht er nicht daraus.
Ja, also ich bin schon, ja, ich hab's schon ein paar Mal vorgehabt, da wegzugehen. Aber wie gesagt, bei mir überwiegt der Faktor, dass es für mich einfach ist.
Ich könnte jederzeit aufhören.
Man muss natürlich sehen, diese Empfehlungssysteme, die sind ja weitestgehend automatischer Natur. Also ich gehe im Moment davon aus, und das ist die letzten Endes ja das immer, was man hofft, dass Google da an der Stelle den Wald vor lauter Bäumen nicht sieht. Es gibt ja zwei Komponenten. Das eine ist quasi, wie nutzen sie das Marketing technisch aus? Und gut, das muss einem bewusst sein, irgendwie müssen sie den Dienst ja auch finanzieren. Es ist aber nicht so, dass einer jetzt speziell in deine Mails rein guckt.
Ich weiß nicht. Ich meine, Yahoo und Google haben Dissidenten in China verraten.
Genau, das ist dann der andere Aspekt. Der andere Aspekt ist halt, wenn es jemand auf dich persönlich abgesehen hat und da kommen dann eben so Autoritäten ins Spiel, wie eben die Staatsanwaltschaft oder wer auch immer. Oder die Regierung, CAA etc. Wenn jemand sagt, also den Stefan Kellner, den knüpfen wir uns jetzt vor und da wollen wir jetzt genau wissen und du Google, du musst uns das jetzt geben, weil sonst darfst du hier nicht mehr investieren oder was auch immer. Dann hat man da natürlich an den Stellen ein Problem. Da hat man aber an vielen Stellen ein Problem, weil selbst wenn ich das alles selbst betreibe, diese Dienste, und ich hab sie auf einem eigenen Server, bin ich am Ende bei einem Provider. Und dieser Provider, der kann auch zur Herausgabe der Daten gezwungen werden. Also da muss man schon sehr, sehr hohe Hürden aufbauen.
Ja gut, aber er kann halt zur Herausgabe der Daten der letzten drei Tage gezwungen werden, aber nicht der letzten zwei Jahre. Also wenn ich mir die E-Mails runterlade, werden die auch nur eine bestimmte Zeit lang zwischendurch gespeichert.
Na ja, also wir haben ja jetzt die neue Vorratsdatenspeicherung gerade in der EU bekommen und da läuft es halt genau darauf hinaus, dass die letzten zwei Jahre nicht die Inhalte, also offiziell zumindest nicht die Inhalte, aber eben auch die Verbindungsdaten, die ja sehr viel wertvoller eigentlich noch sind, weil das Ganze wäre mit wem. Und das ist nämlich auch das zweite Risiko, da wollte ich noch drauf angehen, eben haben wir ja nur von den privaten Daten geredet, also das, wo normalerweise halt keiner reinschauen sollte eigentlich irgendwie. Aber wenn man jetzt halt die Namen der Leute hier im Studio mal in Google eingibt oder auch in andere Suchmaschinen, und wenn man sich ein bisschen auskennt, meine, ihr seid sicherlich schon dabei, so wisst ihr ja alles. Da steht halt so viel drin, was man tut, was man gelassen hat. Und auch diese ganzen neuen Web 2.0 Services laden natürlich gerade dazu ein und die bauen gerade dazu auf, dass man eben sich so einer neuen Öffentlichkeit auch hingibt. Das ist ja auch alles so ein bisschen fleischbeschauend. Man will sich ja auch präsentieren, man will ja jemand sein, man will teilnehmen an dieser neuen Welt, man will nicht untergehen. Also früher haben mich die Leute halt, waren sie ganz beunruhigt. Oh Gott, wenn ich mich jetzt in die Suchmaschine meinen Namen eingebe und so, da findet man ja alles über mich. Und mittlerweile ist es eigentlich genau andersrum. Jetzt kommen die Leute einfach so, oh, ich hab meinen Namen in die Suchmaschine eingeben und ich hab mich nicht gefunden.
Oder andersrum, ich hab 8732 Seiten gefunden, wo mein Name drauf ist.
Die Leute sind jetzt schon bestürzter, wenn sie nicht gefunden werden. Ich darf nicht mitspielen.
Oder Google Fight halt, wo man dann zwei Namen eingibt und man sieht, wer der Gewinner ist. Ich glaub, Tim ist hier im Studio. Punkte?
Was für Punkte mein ich? Felix hat natürlich den Vorteil, dass man seinen Namen nicht falsch schreiben kann. Dieses Problem hab ich ja immer.
Stimmt, das ist mir heute auch passiert.
Ja genau, es gibt viele mögliche Schreibweisen dieses Namens. Also bei Marco geht's schon los, beim Nachnamen dann auch noch. Und dann verliert man bei sowas.
Also Tim Pritloff hat 145.000 Hits. Ich hab nur 25.000.
Und ich hab 23.600. Ich muss noch ein bisschen Gas geben.
Ein bisschen was veröffentlichen.
145.000? Ich hab's in Anführungszeichen geschrieben. Das ist mir schon ein... Es gibt verschiedene Aspekte. Das eine ist, was veröffentliche ich über mich selbst. Und wie lang ist das verfügbar? Das heißt, wenn ich heute eine Page ins Internet stelle und irgendwas über mich darüber schreibe, dann kann es sein, ich lösche die morgen wieder. Und sie ist im Google Cache. Google erhebt ja die Daten auch eine Weile auf. Das heißt, das wird gefunden bei Google. Ich hab's schon abgestellt. Man kann es aber trotzdem noch sehen. Das ist ein Riesenproblem. Ich kann mich bei Google anrufen und sagen, ich hab die Seite runtergenommen, schmeiß das bitte raus, da hab ich schlechte Karten. Das heißt, selbst wenn ich jetzt irgendwas schreib und jemand verklagt mich, und ich nehm das dann runter, ist es immer noch bei Google anleihen. Das ist das eine Problem. Das andere, also das Problem, dass man aus Versehen irgendwas macht, veröffentlicht und es nicht schnell genug wieder runternimmt, und es dann irgendwo kopiert, gespiegelt, noch immer noch über lange, lange Zeit verfügbar ist. Und das andere Problem ist, dass zum Beispiel andere Leute im Veröffentlichungswahn, das heißt, die fotografieren überall alle ihre Freunde und schmeißen das alles ins Internet rein, Bilder von mir da rein schmeißen und dann noch meinen Namen drunter schreiben und ich praktisch keine Kontrolle mehr hab, wer was über mich übermittelt. Und natürlich ist das rechtlich begrenzt. Und natürlich muss man, wenn man jemanden das Daten veröffentlicht oder Bilder veröffentlicht, die Leute vorher fragen. Aber das haben noch nicht alle Leute so richtig gelernt. Sie denken halt, naja gut, ich könnte doch...
Wird auch nicht so durchsetzbar sein.
Wenn man selber dann hingeht und sagt, schmeißt es runter. Aber das ist genauso bei den ganzen Foto-Communities, dass jemand ein Bild von der Straße macht und ich stehe da rum. Ich habe nicht recht am eigenen Bild.
Aber das ist sehr problemlich. Du kannst ja mal deine 146.000 Seiten da durchgehen. Und mal gucken, an welcher Stelle du jemanden verklagst. Das ist ja genau das Problem.
Es ist nicht machbar. Ich habe das schon vor x Jahren auf meine Webseite geschrieben. Da fange ich lieber selber an, was über mich im Web zu erzählen. Dass das Web für über mich irgendwas erzählt. Einfach als vorausschauende Maßnahme. Weil dann kann man zumindest versuchen von Anfang an auch konsistent in seiner Selbstdarstellung zu sein, soweit das möglich ist. Das muss man sehen. Ich kann das auch noch nicht einschätzen. Ich habe auch jedes Mal wieder so ein Ziehen in der Magengegend und habe dieses Abwägen, wenn ich mich irgendwo einlogge, schon wieder ein Login und keine Ahnung und Passwort hier. Und dann sehe ich auch schon, oh Gott, die haben das mit der Verschlüsselung uns hier hinbekommen und Cookies und dieses und jenes. Man weiß, Filme laufen so im Bild, aber man weiß einfach genau, was man jetzt gerade wieder für einen Quatsch macht. Aber es interessiert dann einfach auch zu sehr. Diese Neugier und auch dieser Convenience-Faktor, das ist halt einfach das, was derzeit einfach alle gnadenlos ins Netz zieht. Und man macht sich jetzt gerade erst mal mehr Gedanken darüber, welchen Nutzen man daraus ziehen kann, als welche Gefahren es birgt. Und das kann ich verstehen. Aber an der Stelle müssen wir natürlich auch gerade als Chaos Computer Club mal wieder die Fahne hochhalten und sagen, Leute, denkt zweimal darüber nach, was ihr macht. Hört nicht auf, experimentierfreudig zu sein, aber seid euch zumindest darüber bewusst, was es bedeutet.
Ja, ich meine, es gibt da keine einfache Antwort drauf. Es hat beide seine Vor- und Nachteile. Womit man es vielleicht vergleichen kann, ist durch dieses ganze sogenannte Personal Publishing, also dadurch, dass ich einen Blog hab und dann hab ich noch ein Profil bei einem dieser Social Networks und ich pack meine Bilder ins Netz zu irgendeiner Foto-Community. Dadurch erfahren jetzt im Endeffekt einfache Nutzer oder auch ganz normale Leute, was es heißt, mit Öffentlichkeit umzugehen. Das heißt, denen widerfährt so ein bisschen das, was Prominenten oder Leuten, die in der Öffentlichkeit stehen, schon immer widerfahren ist. Es hat seine Vorteile. Man hat keine Parieren mehr wie früher. Also man kommt leichter zum Beispiel ins Radio. Nein, aber ja gut im Ernst. Also ich meine, im Endeffekt heutzutage Spiegel Online zum Beispiel greift ja auch nur irgendwelche Stories aus Blogs auf. Also wenn ich was Interessantes zu sagen habe, wenn ich zu einem Thema kompetent bin oder wenn ich mich zu einem Thema äußern möchte, dann kann ich das heute sehr viel leichter tun. Und es wird tendenziell auch einfacher entdeckt. Das heißt, ich habe halt auch Möglichkeiten, mich darzustellen mit dem, was ich tue. Ich habe Möglichkeiten, Öffentlichkeit für bestimmte Dinge, die mich interessieren, zu erreichen und damit auch weiterzukommen letzten Endes. Aber es hat eben auch diesen Nachteil, damit stehe ich dann halt auch in der Öffentlichkeit. Das heißt, bestimmte Dinge sind einfach über mich zu erfahren, wie sie früher so in der Form von Bürger zu Bürger nicht so leicht möglich waren. Ich konnte eben nicht alles über meinen Nachbarn nur aufgrund seines Namens rausfinden. Das war halt bestimmten großen Brüdern dann überlassen. Das heißt, man muss also anfangen, so wie man das eben kennt, von diesen, wie heißt der Mensch, mit den Fotos beim Pinkeln und so, der sich ständig mit der Presse prügelt?
Prinz Ernst August.
Man hat also dieses Prügelprinz-Phänomen quasi als einfacher Bürger. Man muss sich also ganz genau überlegen, was sage ich, was tue ich, wie stelle ich mich da und wie wird es auch von anderen aufgefasst und weiterverbreitet. Und natürlich ist es so, dass man auf Dauer sein Bild nicht völlig manipulieren kann. Also wenn man, auf Deutsch gesagt, ein Arschloch ist, dann wird man das auf Dauer nicht verbergen können. Also wenn ich ständig gegen jeden und alles wetter, dann wird es irgendwann noch heißen, der Typ ist ein Arschloch. Aber es gibt natürlich gewisse Dinge, die man eigentlich aus der Öffentlichkeitsarbeit kennt, die ich plötzlich persönliches Öffentlichkeitsmanagement, was ich jetzt erlernen muss und was früher letzten Endes nicht Teil des Skillsets war.
Und dabei entsteht das gleiche Problem, wie Menschen es haben, die plötzlich prominent sind, dass man erst einen Haufen Fehler macht und das dann kaum noch zurückdrehen kann.
Ab sofort sind wir alle prominent.
Jeder hat seine Viertelstunde. Eine Sache ist aber schon anders. Wenn ich jetzt plötzlich prominent werde, wenn mir irgendwas passiert oder die Bild-Zeitung auf mich anspringt, ist es immer noch was anderes, als wenn ich im Web mich veröffentliche. Das sind ja immer Einzelschritte, bei denen ich selbst tätig bin.
Dann kann ich auch auf die Kacke hauen.
Aber bei jedem dieser Einzelschritte kann ich mich noch mal kurz zurücklegen und sagen, will ich das wirklich schreiben. Ein Freund von mir hat sich vor drei Jahren bei Friendster angemeldet und hat total perverses Zeug in sein Profil reingeschrieben. Ich hab das gelesen und gesagt, bist du verrückt? Da ist es doch cool. Zwei Stunden später hat er es wieder runtergenommen, weil er gedacht hat, um Gottes Willen, ich bin ja hier beschäftigt. Danach muss ich mich bewerben. Er googelt jemand und liest das Zeug und denkt, um Gottes Willen, was ist das für ein Idiot?
Das meine ich, klar kannst du aktiv entscheiden, aber normalerweise entdeckst du dieses Medium für dich, gehst da rein und dann wird dir nach einem Jahr oder so, wenn irgendein Typ wie du zu mir kommt, dir bewusst, was habe ich da eigentlich für einen Dreck gebaut?
Das Web vergisst nicht.
Die Analogie geht sogar so weit bis zu den Bildern von Prominenten, von Kindern. Wenn man jetzt ein Kind bekommt, sollte man sich gut überlegen, ob man es schon ins Netz stellt und quasi schon digitale Spuren gegen das Willen des Kindes hinterlässt, bevor es das überhaupt selber entscheiden kann. Und wenn ich dann 13 bin und mich zum ersten Mal googeln, dann finde ich also alle möglichen peinlichen Babyfotos von mir, die Papa so nie hätte reinstellen dürfen.
Das würde ich zum Beispiel nie machen. Es gibt massenhaft Leute, gerade bei Flickr, dem Bilderservice, den wir benutzen, die schmeißen jedes Familienbild, Public, für jeden Lesbar, da rein. Und das würde ich nie machen. Die ganzen Bilder von Leuten, die ich kenne, da frage ich vorher, oder ich mach sie privat, oder mach sie nur bestimmten Leuten zugänglich. Das wäre mir extrem peinlich, wenn mich jemand in der Kneipe fotografiert und ist da postet und ist dann nachher bei Google mit 150 Kommentaren.
Nach dem Places IPO kommt noch die Entführungsgefahr hinzu?
Also ich denke, wir sollten jetzt auch mal erstmal wirklich gerne den Krampf drücken.
Genau. Das Chaos Radio, ihr merkt, es ist der letzte Mittwoch im Monat. Es ist kurz nach elf. Ich bin Marco Seifert, hier heute die Vertretung von Holger Klein und nicht alleine hier, sondern mit Tim Pütler, Felix Petersen und Stefan Kellner. Und den Tim habe ich gerade unterbrochen.
Ja, das habe ich hier nicht übel genommen. Ich wollte, was wollte ich denn? Genau, wir reden jetzt so viel, wir reden so viel Meta über was es denn so alles so gibt. Und ich denke, es wäre mal auch ganz angemessen, mal ein paar Beispiele zu nennen, was so heutzutage auch als Vertreter, als typische Vertreter dieser Web 2.0 Community gilt. Wo wir jetzt gerade bei Fotos sind, müssen wir natürlich anfangen mit Flickr. flickr.com, F-L-I-C-K-R, also ohne das E, was man sich da jetzt vielleicht noch so denkt. Das ist eine Foto Website, die ist, glaube ich, vor so zwei Jahren online gegangen, hat am Anfang noch eine andere Ausrichtung. Da haben die selber noch sehr viel mit Flash rumgespielt, haben dann aber auch schnell ihre ganze Webseite vereinfacht, als sie gemerkt haben, dass sie im Prinzip in so einen Wespenest gestochen haben, mit einer einfachen Methode, Fotos im Internet zu veröffentlichen. Bis dahin war das ja noch so, dass man sich überhaupt erst mal Gedanken machen musste über den notwendigen Platz. Also wenn man damals beim Host da irgendwie gesagt hat, hier ich Web Server, dann haben die einem, keine Ahnung, ein paar Megabyte Platz gegeben. Was für eine große Fotosammlung natürlich nicht ausreicht. Also jede normale Digitalkamera wirft ja heute nach 30 Klicks schon mehr Daten raus als das. Und bei denen war das halt einfach undimitiert. Da konnte man einfach bequem hochladen und das User Interface war irgendwie ganz nett. Und von daher haben sie dann eben auch schnell anderen Diensten, die es zu dem Zeitpunkt schon gab, Konkurrenz gemacht. Aber was noch sehr viel mehr dazu geführt hat, dass Flickr so populär geworden ist, waren zwei Sachen. Erstens haben sie natürlich auch diese Idee des sozialen Netzwerks mit reingebracht. Also man konnte andere Leute so anklicken, du bist mein Freund oder ich kenne dich oder du bist meine Familie und so. Was ja irgendwie komischerweise immer auf ganz großes Interesse steht, weil so kriegt man dann eben auch gleich so alle Fotos von meinen Freunden, die gerade neu hochgeladen wurden. Also es geht gar nicht so sehr um die eigenen Fotos und um das Zeigen, sondern es geht vor allem auch um das Konsumieren, was die anderen alle haben. Also beide Seiten natürlich. Aber das hat beides ganz gut funktioniert. Und eine zweite sehr populäre Methode, die sie sich bei einer anderen Webseite abgeschaut haben, die wir noch gleich erwähnen werden, ist das sogenannte Tagging. Und Tagging ist, glaube ich, kann man sagen, so eine der populärsten Techniken, die sich so entwickelt hat in diesem ganzen Web 2.0. Das zieht sich auch von der einen zur anderen Webseite durch. Die Idee wurde also von ganz vielen Leuten aufgegriffen. Tagging ist, grob gesagt, eine Kategorisierung. Bloß mit einem kleinen Twist. Nämlich, wenn man an Kategorien denkt, dann sieht man halt immer gleich so eine Liste von vorgegebenen Kategorien und dann sucht man sich eine aus. Bei dem Tagging allerdings hat man darauf komplett verzichtet. Ein Tag ist eigentlich nur ein Wort. Das waren natürlich am Anfang vor allem englische Worte. Das heißt, ich habe so ein Foto. Sagen wir mal, ich stehe jetzt am Alex und schieß so ein Familienfoto mit Fernsehturben. Und dann überlege ich mir, was könnte ich da jetzt so für Tags vergeben? Womit könnte ich diese Dinger quasi klassifizieren, kategorisieren? Ja, dann geht man hin und schreibt Berlin, Alexanderplatz, Fernsehturm, Familie, Kinder, Winter, Ferien und so weiter. Also einfach man denkt sich so ein paar Worte aus.
Vor allem man macht das für sich. Das ist glaube ich ein sehr entscheidender Aspekt.
Genau, man macht das, damit man seine Bilder nachher selber besser wiederfindet.
Und das Phänomen ist, dass halt dann irgendwie eigentlich die meisten Leute auch dieselben Tags für dieselben Sachen verwenden. Und auf einmal war diese Tagging eben nicht nur eine gute Suchmethode für einen selbst, sondern eben auch eine gute Suchmethode nach allem. Man kann also bei Flickr reinmarschieren und sagen, gib mir mal Fotos, die halt diesem und diesem Tag entsprechen. Also wenn ich so eine Präsentation mache und ich brauche halt immer ein schickes Bild irgendwie so im Hintergrund, dann ist das einfach für mich die erste Adresse. Neulich hab ich mal, brauchte ich halt meine ganze Batterie von alten Radios, das hab ich da in einer halben Stunde mein Bedürfnis befriedigen können, nämlich ich halt einfach nach Radio gesucht habe. Und diese Methode ist halt sehr populär. Es gibt dann noch eine zweite Website, die das halt eigentlich mal, das waren doch die ersten, oder? Ich hab's da das erste Mal wahrgenommen.
Da hab ich's auch das erste Mal gesehen, ich hab aber auch schon gehört, dass sie es nicht erfunden haben.
Aber ich denke, es ist ohne Zweifel, sie haben es populär gemacht. Sie hatten eine ganz einfache Methode, bei denen im Prinzip funktionieren sie genauso wie Flickr nur, da geht's nicht um Fotos, sondern es geht einfach nur um Bookmarks, also um Adressen im Web. Das heißt, wenn ich durch die Gegensurfer und ich hab was Interessantes, mach ich halt meinen Bookmark nicht in meinem Browser, sondern ich mach ihn halt bei Delicious. Die haben so ein paar kleine, einfache Widgets, die ich mir so in meinen Browser reinwerfen kann, sodass es so mit einem Klick, ich bin auf der Seite, ich klick da so drauf, dann geh ich gleich zu Delicious, dann ist die URL gleich mit übernommen, dann schreibe ich eine kurze Beschreibung rein und dann eben auch Tags, speicher das ab und dann ist das eben unter meinem Account bei Delicious abgespeichert. Im Prinzip habe ich eine URL veröffentlicht, so wie man bei Flickr ein Bild veröffentlicht, aber eben auch mit Tags. Und andere Leute können halt meinen Datenstrom an neuen Bookmarks abonnieren und den verfolgen oder sie können halt auch mit Tags danach suchen und so weiter. Und das ist innerhalb kürzester Zeit sehr populär geworden. Und auf einmal war das die beste Quelle, um cooles Zeug zu finden. Weil, wenn ich irgendwie wissen will, was es gerade heißt im Internet, dann gucke ich einfach bei Delicious nach, was sind die populärsten URLs. Weil wenn jetzt irgendwas mal total angesagt ist und das spricht sich ja in Windeseile rum, mittlerweile sind ja so die Turnaround-Zeiten, also länger als 24 Stunden, braucht eine Nachricht heute nicht mehr, um weltweit bekannt zu sein. Und zwar auch so affiges Zeug, so was weiß ich hier, diese Chinesen da mit ihren Nachswingevideos und so, das kennt irgendwie jeder, wenn man sich so halbwegs regelmäßig im Internet rumtun. Weil das eben durch diese Sites so nach vorne gepusht wird.
Und ich glaube an Tags, das ist ein sehr schönes Beispiel, um diesen sogenannten kollaborativen Aspekt von Web 2.0 ein bisschen zu vertiefen. Was halt schön ist an Tags ist, man muss sich nicht auf so eine sogenannte gemeinsame Weltsicht einigen. Also vorher gab es, es gibt natürlich dann immer Schlaumeier, die sagen, naja, aber der eine der schreibt einen Fernsehturm und der andere TV Tower oder einer schreibt Germany, einer schreibt Deutschland oder einer schreibt Hund, die andere schreibt Hunde. Ja, das ist so und man wird sicherlich, wenn man Hund eingibt bei Flickr, einige Hundefotos auch verpassen. Aber dadurch, dass es eben so wahnsinnig viele Leute machen, ist diese Unschärfe auch okay, weil ich finde immer noch genug Hundefotos. Wenn ich Tokio eingebe, kriege ich halt meine 23.000 Fotos. Das sind wahrscheinlich mehr Fotos von Tokio, als ich jemals verbrauchen kann. Weil die Alternative, die ist halt keine. Die Alternative wäre halt, man setzt sich gemeinsam hin und überlegt sich, wie man die Welt eigentlich so erklärt, verschlagwortet und kategorisiert. Weil bei Fotos geht es ja um nichts anderes als um die ganze Welt. Dann würde der eine das halt nach Ländern runter machen, der andere alphabetisch. Und auf diese gemeinsame Welt kann man sich so nicht einigen. Daran sind früher auch viele Standards gescheitert, dass sich also drei, vier, fünf Firmen zusammentun wollten und so ein Standard machen, der das Internet weiterbringt. Und genau wie es mit den Standards so ist, ist es auch mit den Tags, den Kategorien, die User, die bauen die sich jetzt selbst. Und dadurch gibt es auch diese sogenannten Trampelfade, die sich dann ergeben. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel Tags von anderen Leuten sehe und ich sehe, aha, die schreiben also alle Hund und Hund ist relativ populär, dann werde ich wahrscheinlich auch Hund übernehmen und nicht den lateinischen Namen für Hund, den ich jetzt auch gerade nicht verraten habe. Ja, genau. Das heißt, es ergeben sich sogenannte Trampelfade im Gegensatz zu dem, was man vorher hatte im Webben. Das waren nämlich Autobahnen, die irgendwie zentral gebaut mit 16-jähriger Planungsphase und Feststellungsverfahren und was weiß ich. Und dann wurde sie am Ende nicht gebaut. Und das ist das Schöne, es wird alles sehr flexibel, sehr schnell, user-kontrolliert. Ja, das ist, glaube ich, ein ganz, ganz entscheidender Aspekt. Und das kann man an Tags sehr schön sehen, sehr einfach.
Ja, es funktioniert halt nicht überall mit Tags. Also das ist ja so der Widerstreit zwischen Taxonomie, also der wissenschaftlich exakten Kategorisierung von Dingen und der sogenannten Folxonomie.
Das war ja gerade gehakt, schön.
Also diese Tags nennt man Folxonomie. Folxonomie ist praktisch das Pornor dazu, zur Taxonomie. Das ist das Volk, die Leute, die irgendwelche Sachen einbeieben. Das Volk, das. Genau. Ein Problem dabei ist halt, das funktioniert da, wo man unheimlich viele Daten hat. Also wenn jetzt beispielsweise bei Flickr die Leute Bilder einspielen und ich will ein Bild von Tokio und ich gebe da Tokio ein und ich finde da 500.000 Bilder, dann reicht mir das völlig aus, wenn ich mir eher die ersten 200 anschaue. Wenn ich bei Wikipedia im Lexikon, im öffentlichen Lexikon, das von Josef gepflegt wird, was ich suche, dann brauch ich die Taxonomie. Weil da finde ich unter Umständen nicht das, was ich suche. Es gibt halt verschiedene Bereiche, wo man halt taxonomisch arbeiten muss und wo man andererseits wieder bei Massendaten mit anderen Methoden.
Da können wir natürlich auch mal eine Diskussion darüber führen, ob Wikipedia das Tagging nicht vielleicht auch ganz gut tun kann. Zusätzlich wird es auf jeden Fall helfen, weil die Taxonomie kriege in der Wikipedia. Das ist dann noch mal so eine ganz andere Geschichte. Ja, die funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut, aber vielleicht könnte es noch besser funktionieren.
Ja, und das Entscheidende, das hat ja Felix schon erwähnt, ist der ist praktisch der der Altruismus, der dahinter steckt. Ich gehe bei Flickr rein, weil da habe ich einen Platz, wo ich meine Bilder hinschmeißen kann und ich sortiere die für mich. Der Egoismus. Ja, der Egoismus. Ich sortiere die für mich. Genau das Gegenteil. Und dann habe ich die in Ordnung und da finde ich die leicht. Und gleichzeitig entsteht dadurch was anderes. Und diese ganzen Dienste, also bei der Lüschens ist das genauso, ich organisiere meine Links. Und die ganzen Dienste basieren auf ganz klaren Hilfen für mich selbst, für den User. Und nur so funktioniert irgendwas. Wikipedia ist es ein bisschen anders, aber das sind auch nur sehr wenige Leute, wenn man alle User nimmt, alle, die es lesen, alle, die schreiben, ist es ein relativ kleiner Anteil derer, die schreibt. Weil da gehört sehr viel dazu zu sagen, ich stelle mich jetzt dahin und ich schreibe was. Und es könnte ja auch falsch sein, dann verbessert es jemand und so. Aber wenn ich meine eigenen Bilder sortiere, da ist die Hürde nicht so groß.
Was halt cool ist an so Dingen wie Tagging oder auch dem, was Google damals eingeführt hat. Google hat ja am Anfang gesagt, also bevor es Google gab, hat man gesagt, wir zählen einfach die Anzahl der Wörter, die auf einer Seite vorkommen. Und wenn du ein Wort eingibst und das Wort, was du eingegeben hast, kommt da oft vor, dann wird das schon relevant sein. Und dann kamen natürlich schlaue Leute auf die Idee und haben dieses Wort einfach tausendmal unsichtbar auf die Seite geschrieben. Sogenannte Suchmaschinenspam. Und Google hatte dann eine ganz coole Idee. Und die waren nämlich die ersten, die eigentlich so ein kollaboratives System eingeführt haben. Das muss man ja auch mal sagen. Also viele der Dinge, die jetzt unter Web 2.0 laufen, sind halt schon lange kommerziell erfolgreich, wie zum Beispiel bei Google. Das ist der sogenannte PageRank. Die haben halt gesagt, na ja, wenn viele Leute auf diese Seite linken und sich quasi die Mühe machen, einen Link zu produzieren, dann wird die schon wichtig sein für dieses Thema. Und das war im Endeffekt schon das erste kollaborative System. Was daran sehr schön ist, es wird immer besser, umso mehr Daten es gibt. Und das Internet wächst ja tendenziell ganz stark an. Also es wird immer mehr Daten geben. Und so was wie es am Anfang gab, so ein sogenanntes Directory, also so ein Verzeichnis, wo sich jemand hinsetzt und dann alle Websites, die es im Internet gab, sortiert und irgendwie kategorisiert.
Also hat ja nur angefangen.
Genau, das ist natürlich sehr, sehr schnell an seine Grenzen gestoßen. Und man braucht sicherlich tendenziell im Internet Systeme, die eher besser werden und schärfer werden, umso mehr Leute Daten einstellen und diese Daten verschlagworten. Und so ist es bei Tags und so ist es bei dem Google Page Rank. Es gibt so ein paar ganz einfache Regeln, wenn man die beachtet. Dann kann man vielleicht auch eine Vorhersage darüber treffen, welche Dinge erfolgreich sein werden und welche nicht.
Ich würde gern die Hörer dazu holen. Und worüber würdest du gern mit ihnen reden, Tim? Ja, vorhin hatten wir einen Anrufer, der wurde dann relativ schnell verabschiedet.
Er hat keine Frage gestellt in dem Sinne.
Wir haben jetzt Matthias, 29 Jahre alt, aus Berlin-Stegels, der schon eine Weile wartet und hoffentlich noch da ist.
Ja, bin ich noch. Also ich habe jetzt in der Zwischenzeit, die ich gewartet habe, ehrlicherweise mal bei Wikipedia wirklich Web 2.0 eingegeben, weil der Begriff als solches war mir noch nicht bekannt. Also noch irgendwo mal aufgeschnappt. Mir auch nicht. Ich dachte, das wäre jetzt irgendwie eine Software oder Sonstiges und habe mir das ein bisschen durchgelesen und bin dann direkt auf Ajax gestoßen und kramte dann in meinen Bookmarks im Browser und fand tatsächlich Ajax Right. Ich weiß nicht, ob euch das jetzt ein Begriff ist. Denke ich schon, ja. Und ohne dass ich es gemerkt habe, habe ich praktisch diese Web 2.0 schon die ganze Zeit immer mal wieder benutzt, ohne es eigentlich jemand gemerkt zu haben. Also jetzt, wenn man mal schnell was machen kann, ist es durchaus eine Alternative. Aber auf diese Software kann man dann noch im späteren nicht verzichten. Ich wollte aber noch vorher sagen, wie das bei mir eigentlich angefangen hat. Ich habe irgendwie auch Ende der 90er Jahre angefangen, im Internet zu surfen, bzw. fing an zu chatten, ging dann hin über Surfen, alles noch mit Modem. Und als dann die ganzen Technologien hochkamen, dann kamen die ganzen, ich baue mir meine Internet-Homepage selber, dann ging es mit der Uni los. Wir sind mit dem Informationsfluss von der Uni nicht zufrieden, wir bauen eine eigene Page für Studenten. Und so hat sich das alles entwickelt bis dahin, dass wir jetzt auch natürlich Google Mail verlinken, oder wir geben, wir nennen es ja das Google Video zum Beispiel, auch eine ganz tolle Sache, das bisher noch nicht thematisiert worden bei euch. Also alles von Google ist bisher genannt worden, das sind zum Kalender, der noch Alpha ist, aber Google Video ist ja praktisch auch, würde man auch zu Web 2.0 kategorisieren. Das ist der reinste Wahnsinn. Oder YouTube oder die ganzen Community Sites, die sich mit diesem Publizieren von privaten Videos beschäftigen, das wäre der reinste Wahnsinn. Und Google Mail ist ja dahingehend, was wir so einbinden in dieses Embedded, wie er so schön heißt, ist ja der Vorreiter, finde ich jedenfalls.
Ja, wir haben auf eine Sache noch gar nicht wirklich Bezug genommen, was das Web 2.0 ausmacht, das heißt diese sogenannten Mesh-ups. Das heißt also einzelne Anbieter stellen Komponenten bereit, wie Google die Videos oder die Google Maps. Und andere Leute, die die Websites machen, können aus diesen Komponenten neue Dinge bauen, die man dann Mesh-ups nennt, also eine Mischung aus verschiedenen Sachen. Und das ermöglicht ganz, ganz viele neue Sachen, die die Dienste gar nicht selber entwickeln könnten, weil sie vielleicht gar nicht daran gedacht hätten, dass man diese Informationen so vermengen kann.
Aber ich finde es auch sehr interessant, dass du im Endeffekt diese Dienste nutzt. Du hast jetzt auch zwei, drei andere Dienste genannt wie YouTube, die man absolut als Web 2.0 bezeichnen würde. Und ich finde es interessant zu sehen, dass sich offensichtlich diese Dienste durchsetzen, dass die Leute die Dienste gut finden, ohne das jetzt auszuprobieren, weil es eben Web 2.0 ist, wie es vielleicht einige Alfa-Nerds tun.
Ja, vor allen Dingen diesen Begriff Web 2.0, den merkt man gar nicht. Also man macht es einfach. Man läuft mit dem Fluss, mit dem Mainstream, geht man durch und nimmt alles mit, was man eigentlich Neues kriegen kann, weil eben, mein Gott, man öffnet eine Website und geht auf irgendeinen Link und die Seite baut sich jetzt zum Beispiel nicht neu auf, sondern wie ihr es gesagt habt, da bleibt man praktisch auf der einen Ebene und man findet es toll und sucht nach Sachen, die praktisch eh nicht funktionieren und so verbreitet sich das Ganze.
Ja, einfach besser als vorher, oder?
Ja genau, und so soll es ja auch sein, ja.
Ja, richtig, ganz genau. Und irgendwie jeder Nutzer von unserem Portal, sag ich jetzt mal, also ich hab dann, wie gesagt, in der Uni mit ein paar Leuten dann so ein Portal eröffnet und die dann es einmal auch. Also es wird viel, viel schneller genutzt jetzt auch, die ganzen Dinge. Also einfach der Informationsfluss ist viel, viel höher, weil es schneller geht. Die meisten, also viele Leute, die haben auch kein DSL oder was auch immer, die laufen immer noch mit einem 28er Modem durch und klopfen da die Mauszeichen rein, damit sie eine Webseite kriegen und das natürlich dann viel schneller nutzen.
Da hört man bei YouTube dann auch keinen Spaß an.
Nee, ist richtig. 26 MB mal eben, das ist dann schon ein bisschen schwieriger. Auf jeden Fall eine tolle Sache. Was das Bloggen angeht, ich bin da oft aufgesprungen, hab dann irgendwann bei Blogabkommen so einen Blog eröffnet und dachte mir so, was schreibst du jetzt da rein? Schreibst du jetzt was über dich? Schreibst du irgendwas, was du am täglichen Leben aufgeschnappt hast? Oder was machst du denn jetzt damit eigentlich? Also einfach so einen Blog eröffnen, weiß ich nicht.
Hast du das jetzt gemacht oder nicht?
Ich hab mir einen Blog eröffnet und hab da jetzt drei Posts drauf geschrieben, was mir gerade so gedankenreich ist einfiel, aber jetzt so richtig mich präsentieren im Internet, wüsste ich jetzt nicht, was ich Leuten präsentieren möchte.
Aber du hattest irgendwie gedacht, das macht jetzt jeder, deswegen ich auch, und dann saß du da vorne und dachtest, was nun?
Richtig. Also eigentlich ziemlich dumm, muss man wirklich sagen, weil eigentlich sollte man vorher ein Konzept haben und sich überlegen, warum brauche ich das und was mache ich damit, aber vielleicht wird es ja noch oder...
Ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich der Ansatz sein sollte. Also ich meine, ich finde es auch gut, wenn man das einfach erstmal ausprobiert und dann guckt man halt, ob dafür ein irgendwas zu holen ist, ohne dass man sich jetzt vorher einen Plan macht, weil die Pläne verfallen dann sowieso.
Man muss auch nicht bloggen. Also ich glaube, das ist ganz interessant.
Aber dieses Gefühl hatte Matthias auch gemacht.
Ja, na sicher. Blogging ist ein interessantes Beispiel, weil das jetzt auch schon länger um die Ecke ist, seit vier, fünf Jahren. Und da gibt es jetzt die ersten, die von Bloggingmüdigkeit, Bloggingdepression reden. Bloggingfatigue. Ja, weil sicherlich...
Pot fading.
Gibt es das auch schon?
Ja, das gibt es auch schon.
Ja gut, ich meine, das ist immer so mit neuer Technologie. Man probiert sie aus und am Ende macht halt keiner etwas um der Sache selbst Willen. Also wenn man sich was in der Öffentlichkeit mitteilen will und irgendwie Dinge veröffentlicht und in der Diskussion mit anderen Leuten stehen möchte zu bestimmten Themen, ist Blogging sicherlich super. Wenn man eine schöne Stimme hat und schon immer Radio machen wollte, ist Podcasting sicherlich auch super, aber es ist ja eben nicht alles für jeden. Und diese Blogs, die sich mit dem Bloggen beschäftigen, die werden halt auf Dauer eben auch nicht mehr so wichtig sein.
Ja, und es kommt ja aber noch mehr dazu. Das Musikproduzieren kommt rein, ich hab vorhin schon drüber gesprochen, Myspace ist sehr populär, jetzt kommt diese Vlogging-Geschichte. Also Video-Vlogging ist dann für alle Leute, die eben gerne sowas machen. Für jeden ist eigentlich was dabei im Internet und übrig bleiben halt die, die jetzt eigentlich überhaupt nicht mehr dazu beitragen wollen. Aber ich denke, extrem viele Leute wollen halt eigentlich beitragen. Und das ist auch sehr gut, weil das ist aktive Beteiligung an der Gesellschaft und das ist mir immer noch lieber, als wenn sich keiner beteiligt.
Und das ist vor allen Dingen extrem einfach. Also ich meine, ihr habt eben das Beispiel mit HTML und XML angebracht, wie die ganzen Codereien, dass das eigentlich für wissenschaftliche Arbeiten gedacht war. Und dann kam ich direkt auf das Beispiel, auf die Idee, Mensch, LaTeX ist ja, oder TeX ist ja, als ich damit angefangen hab zu arbeiten, das ist gar nicht so lange her, hab ich mir gedacht, Mensch, das ist doch fast wie HTML. Also vom Prinzip her, dachte ich mir so, oh mein Gott, mittlerweile kennt man dann schon die Grundbefehle, genauso wie dann irgendwann mal beim HTML, dann ging es rüber zu PHP und die ganzen Showsen da. Also im Grunde genommen war es dasselbe und man muss sich um nichts kümmern, damit man es kann. Und für die Leute, die da sich nicht reinzucksen wollen, gibt es noch so schöne Sachen fürs Internet, Website Baker oder diese Sachen, wo man mit fünf Klicks nur jemanden braucht, der einem die PHP-Datenbank erstellt und den Rest macht man dann selber.
Ja gut, das ist ja nun schon sehr advanced.
Oder Weblogs, wo du gar nichts mehr machen musst.
Weblogs oder noch einfacher. Ich meine, ein Weblog ist immer technisch einfacher, aber du sitzt von einem leeren Stück Papier. Letzten Endes, das wirkliche Massenphänomen ist sowas wie MySpace. Weil ich da auch eine gewisse Anleitung habe, also ich habe genug kreative Freiheit, aber das war auch letzten Endes der Erfolg für MySpace im Vergleich zu anderen Diensten. Ich habe genug Freiheit, mein Profil zu pimpen, wie man so schön sagt. Auf der anderen Seite habe ich halt eine gewisse Anleitung, also hier bitte schreib was über deine Bücher und da lad deine Fotos hoch. Es ist also nicht ganz so dieses leere Blatt Papier, es ist ein bisschen strukturierter. Und das ist das wirkliche Massenphänomen. Tatsache ist, jeder fängt an zu kontribuieren, der im Internet ist. Also ich glaube die Mitgliederzahlen von MySpace, die gleichen sich langsam, aber sicher der Gesamteilnehmerschaft des Internets an. Also statistisch hat bald jeder Internetnutzer einen MySpace-Account. Das geht in die Richtung. Also MySpace flacht die Wachstumsrate langsam ab, weil es eben an die natürlichen Wachstumsgrenzen stößt.
Von was für Zahlen reden wir da jetzt gerade?
Das können wir gleich mal nachgucken bei Alexa oder so. Also auf jeden Fall ist MySpace locker in die Top 3, Top 4 des Internets vorgeschossen.
Ach du meinst jetzt an Zugriffen, nicht an Accounts.
Ja, doch Accounts geht auch, das ist brutal. Nee, das kann ja wohl nicht sein. Wir reden auf jeden Fall von mehreren hundert Millionen.
Aber das liegt doch vermutlich daran, dass ganz viele...
Mehrere hundert Millionen?
Ja, dass ganz viele Menschen ganz viele Zugänge haben, also einzelne Menschen haben, sonst kann ich es mir nicht erklären.
So viele sind das nicht.
Also allein in meinem Netzwerk, und ich hab nicht viele Freunde bei MySpace, um genau zu sein, glaube ich zwei oder drei, sind 73.969.644.
Da siehst du immer, wie wertvoll dieses Netzwerk ist. Du solltest die alle mal anrufen, wenn sie mit Essen entlangwachsen.
Das glaube ich nicht. Das ist ja das. MySpace war ein Phänomen, was völlig von hinten kam, wo man plötzlich überhaupt nicht mehr dran vorbei konnte und wo auch plötzlich, man hat am Anfang ganz reines Kiddie-Ding abgetan.
Aber solche Zahlen führen noch dazu, dass sich jetzt jeder schlecht fühlt, der keinen Account da hat und es noch weiter nach vorne gebracht wird.
Wikipedia meint, sie hätten so viel.
Tim zum Beispiel fühlt sich ganz schlecht gerade.
Total. 74 Millionen.
Du kennst fast alle. Ja, das ist unwahrscheinlich.
Du kennst wirklich alle, ne?
Ich heiße nochmal der Gast bei euch, der von Google weggehen wollte.
Von Google Mail wollte ich weggehen.
Ich wäre da sehr vorsichtig bei diesem neuen Google Kalender. Ich finde es erschreckend, dass jemand seine kompletten Termine, die er meinetwegen auf iCal, auf seinem Mac hat zum Beispiel, und dann komplett seinen privaten und Arbeitskalender published und da mehr oder weniger öffentlich zugänglich macht. Okay, dann müsste ich ihm noch einen Account hacken, aber Google selber könnte ja auf deine gesamten Aktivitäten, nicht nur E-Mails, Zugriff haben. Das finde ich noch viel schlimmer als die E-Mails. Da kann man ja immer noch ein bisschen was bremsen, aber das geht immer, Google ist ja schon ein bisschen, naja, nicht Big Brother is watching you, aber schon ein bisschen kritisch.
Wie gesagt, ich habe im Moment keine Bedenken an Google, weil das wäre für Google ein extrem großes Problem.
Denn du Bedenken hättest?
Im Moment habe ich keine Bedenken gegenüber Google. Aber allein die Tatsache, dass man alles einer Firma anvertraut ist, ist an sich schon sehr bedenklich.
Im Moment hat Google gar kein Interesse daran, diese Daten rauszugeben, weil das ja quasi ihre Kunden bedroht. Aber es gab ja jetzt in den letzten Monaten verschiedene Anfragen, nenne ich das jetzt mal, von der amerikanischen Regierung, ob man denn nicht mal hier und da und überhaupt und die Terrorismusgefahr und so. Und während Yahoo und andere da sehr schnell klein beigegeben haben, hat Google es durchgefordert, zumindest in diesem einen bekannt gewordenen Fall. Das heißt ja nicht, dass es, die amerikanische Terrorgesetzgebung erlaubt es derzeit, einfach dem Staat da hinzugehen zu sagen, du musst es uns jetzt geben und du bist verpflichtet, es niemandem zu sagen.
Das wollte ich sagen. Also das eine ist das Fragen und das andere ist, es gibt in einem Land, auf das wir keinen Zugriff haben, eine Gesetzesänderung. Und darüber können wir gerne weiter reden. Matthias, magst du noch dranbleiben, weil wir müssen jetzt eine kurze Pause machen?
Ja, ich hab nur noch dann noch eine Frage.
Okay, aber dann, also wir haben dich ja angerufen, dann bleib einfach dran. Es ist nämlich jetzt kurz nach halb 12 und gleich gibt es hier die Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr.
Am 2. September treffen sich. Wir sind Helden. Und Tomte. Denn endlich kommt nach Berlin, was auch so heißt. Fritz präsentiert Berlin Nova. Mit Tomte, Jimmy Eadworld und Wir sind Helden. Und ganz bestimmt vielleicht kommt auch Kate Moss Ex-Freund Pete Doherty mit seiner Band den Baby Shambles. Am 2. September in der Waldbühne. Solang's noch Karten gibt, gibt's Karten überall wo's Karten gibt.
Fritz vom RBB 23.33 Uhr. Fritz Info mit Gerald Kötter-Heinrich.
Bundeskanzlerin Merkel und der russische Präsident Putin haben in Sibirien über die künftige Zusammenarbeit beider Länder beraten. Merkel wird bei ihrer Reise von mehreren Ministern und einer Wirtschaftsselegation begleitet. Zu Beginn ihres Aufenthaltes hatte sie den Abschluss von Wirtschaftsverträgen angekündigt. Beim ersten Treffen mit Putin wurde unter anderem das Thema Energieversorgung behandelt. Zehntausende Menschen in der Ukraine und vielen anderen Ländern haben der Reaktorkatastrophe von Tschernobyl vor 20 Jahren gedacht. In Schweigeminuten wurde an einer Schicksal der Strahlenopfer erinnert. Auch in Deutschland fanden zahlreiche Gedenkveranstaltungen statt. US-Ausministerin Rice und Verteidigungsminister Rumsfeld sind überraschend nach Bagdad gereist. Mit dem Besuch wollen beide den designierten Ministerpräsidenten Al Maliki unterstützen, hieß es. Rumsfeld sprach in Bagdad über die langfristige amerikanische Militärpräsenz im Irak. Arbeitsverträge dürfen nicht allein wegen des Alters des Arbeitnehmers befristet werden. Mit dieser Entscheidung hat das Bundesarbeitsgericht eine zentrale Regelung der Arbeitsmarktreform Hartz IV für ungültig erklärt. Die in den Reformgesetzten festgelegte Altersgrenze von 52 Jahren ab der befristete Verträge zulässig sind, Verstoße gegen den Gleichheitsgrundsatz urteilte das Gericht. Der FC Barcelona steht zum zweiten Mal im Finale der Champions League. Das Halbfinale-Rückspiel gegen den AC Mailand endete 0-0 unentschieden. Nach dem 1-0-Hinspiel-Sieg spielt Barcelona jetzt im Finale gegen Arsenal London. Heute Nacht kann es noch kurze Schauer und Gewitter geben. Die Temperaturen sinken auf 11 bis 8 Grad. Und morgen gibt es im Westen Brandenburgs weiterhin noch Schauer. Richtung Oder und Neiße bleibt es trocken. Die Temperaturen steigen auf 15 bis 20 Grad. Der Verkehr fritzt mit einer Meldung Stadt Autobahn Berlin A100 weddigen Richtung Wilmersdorf. Die Autobahn ist zwischen Charlottenburg und Hohenzollern-Damm heute Nacht bis 5 Uhr frühmorgen wegen Instandhaltungsarbeiten gesperrt. Ansonsten keine aktuellen Meldungen. Gute Fahrt.
Und wann im Radio 101, 5? Dann fritt's in Eisenhüttenstadt.
Ihr hört immer noch den Blue Moon, das Chaos Radio am Mittwochabend. Es ist kurz nach halb 12 und wir redeten gerade hier mit Matthias, 29 Jahre alt, aus Berlin Steglitz und ich hoffe, er ist immer noch da. Bist du noch da?
Ich bin noch da.
Das ist doch schön.
Eine Frage hattest du noch?
Ich hab noch eine Frage und zwar eine rein technische Frage und zwar bleiben wir doch mal beim Thema Google Mail. Wie schaffen die Betreiber, dass jeder User und es kommen ja täglich hunderte dazu, sag ich jetzt mal, jedem User 2, 7 Gigabyte stetig steigend zur Verfügung zu stellen?
Gute Frage. Erst mal benutzen natürlich nicht alle das und die haben nicht wirklich die zwei oder vier Gigabyte, die sie dir versprechen, wirklich auch für dich. Also wenn jeder die benutzen würde, hätten sie ein Problem.
Da sind wir wieder bei der Bank, wir werden alle auf einmal das Geld abheben.
Aber Google hat definitiv jetzt schon den höchsten Stromverbrauch von allen Unternehmen auf diesem Planeten und die iterieren das halt aus. Ja, so eine Meldung gab es vor ein paar Tagen. Ich bin mir das Wahrheitsgehalt der Meldung nicht ganz sicher, aber da gibt es noch die Aluminium Industrie. Die haben ja eh ein Stromproblem in Kalifornien. Das hatten wir ja vor zwei Jahren, wo immer irgendwie einfach nicht genug Strom ran gekarrt werden konnte und das ist auf jeden Fall auch ein Thema. Aber sie machen es halt einfach so, indem sie sehen, wie sich ihre Benutzerzahlen entwickeln. Sie haben permanent die Statistik, wieviel auch davon wirklich benutzt wird und die stecken im Prinzip eine Festplatte nach der anderen da rein.
Aber, das ist sehr interessant, Open Source macht es möglich. Google hat da, glaube ich, somit als erste im ganz großen Stil eigentlich frei verfügbare Hardware, also PCs im Endeffekt, die ich in jedem Laden kaufen kann, rangeschleppt. Und haben eben eher auf Masse und auf Open Source auf Linux gesetzt und haben die Sachen so angepasst, dass sie halt in riesigen Clustern auch funktionieren. Früher wäre das sicherlich so nicht möglich gewesen, weil dann mit jedem Gmail-Account mehr eben dann der Oracle-Server, der Sun-Server mit Oracle drauf hätte rangekarrt werden müssen. Und das wäre sehr teuer geworden. Also auch da haben sicherlich Open Source-Technologien vieles erst möglich gemacht.
Vor allem gab es, es gab ja mal das Gegenbeispiel, der Web-Hoster Strato hat ja vor ein paar Jahren alle 2 Millionen Domains, damals waren das noch, alle 2 Millionen Websites auf einen Server gepackt. Und es ging, glaube ich, anderthalb Monate nicht gut. Also die waren da irgendwie jeden zweiten Tag down.
Das heißt auf einen Computer?
Die haben eine riesige E-10000 gekauft und alles reingesteckt und haben alle Domains auf einem Computer gehostet. Und das war, das hat nie funktioniert. Also gerade sind Cluster Open Source-Dinger, die haben wahrscheinlich eine Riesenhalle mit PCs. Und wenn irgendetwas, wenn irgend einer kaputt geht, dann schmeißt man dann raus und hängt einen anderen rein.
Ja, ich meine, die zahlen ja auch wahrscheinlich gar nichts dafür, dass sie die Komponenten da irgendwie bekommen. Ich meine, mit dem, mit der Lobby, die sie haben.
Ach, ich glaube schon.
Nein, also im Vergleich also.
Die haben ja auch ein bisschen Geld, ne?
Ja, eben. Die haben da wahrscheinlich kein Problem mit. Eine letzte Sache, die ich noch eben sagen wollte, wenn man sich unsicher fühlt, was das ganze Publischen und Bloggen und Podcasts oder sowas nicht sicher ist und meint, das wäre nicht so toll, man kann sich ja einfach da raushalten. Das ist so die Quintessenz, die ich jetzt die ganze Zeit rausgezogen hab. Man muss es ja nicht machen.
Man kann sich raushalten und man kann sich natürlich auch Pseudonyme zulegen. Man kann sich in vielen Diensten einfach auch mit einem Pseudonym anmelden, mit einer Einmal-E-Mail-Adresse oder man holt sich bei GameX irgendeine. Und probiert es einfach mal Pseudonym aus, bis man ein bisschen Vertrauen gewinnt. Ich denke, das ist so der beste Tipp, den man da geben kann.
Wobei auf deinem und meinem Blog glaube ich unsere realen Namen nicht einmal erwähnt sind. Und trotzdem, wenn du es googlest, kommen eben bei vielen Leute drauf linken mit den vollen Namen und dann am Ende finden sie es ja doch.
Also ich hatte auf meinem Blog früher, also bis vor einem halben Jahr, meinen Namen nicht drauf. Und es war trotzdem der erste Hit bei Google. Ja, weil andere Leute halt mit meinem Namen auf meinem Blog linken und Google ja die Links auswertet.
Ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen Abend.
Matthias, danke für deinen Anruf. Manfred wartet schon eine ganze Weile und er ruft aus Wien an. Hallo. Hallo.
Hallo Tim. Schöne Grüße aus Wien. Er warst ja vor kurzem bei mir in der Sendung. Ich habe mir jetzt euer Thema durchgelesen und dachte zuerst an Web 2.0, an Internet 2.0, das was so der Begriff war für ein Internet, das was so im akademischen Bereich, glaube ich, gebaut wird, wenn ich da richtig informiert bin. Mir ging es jetzt ähnlich so wie dem Hörer vorher, dass ich auch erst einmal durch Google oder durch GbD schlau gemacht habe. Und was mich jetzt bei der speziellen Sache interessieren würde, ist, vor 10 Jahren haben wir noch eigentlich mit dem Purismus gekämpft und durch die Kommerzialisierung des Netzes haben wir uns ja eher gewährt, dass die Bandbreiten verschwendet werden. Und jetzt taucken wir ganz lustig und monta über Web 2.0, als hätte es nichts normaleres gegeben als das immer. Und eigentlich sind ja diese Begriffe wie auf den kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner Rücksichtsvernehmers sowie bei E-Mail eben keine HTML-Mails zu verwenden. Einfach, was man natürlich heute noch machen sollte, aber irgendwie scheint sich im Wandel der Zeit etwas geändert zu haben. Ist für dir das?
Das hat definitiv was geändert. Ich glaube, was du meinst, ist, dass dieses Internet 2, das bezog sich eher auf den Ausbau des Internet mit schnellen Datenleitungen. Das hat aber so mit dem Web 2.0 in dem Sinne nichts zu tun. Man kann natürlich auch genauso gut von einem Internet 2.0 sprechen und nicht nur von einem Web 2.0, im Web wird es halt am sichtbarsten. Aber im Prinzip gibt es ja auch noch andere Technologien, die man da auch genauso unter diesem Deckmantel Web 2.0 fasst, sagen wir mal so Peer-to-Peer-Kommunikation, BitTorrent, diese ganzen Filesharing-Protokolle gehören ja im Prinzip auch mit rein, die ja auch ein extremes soziales Phänomen haben. Einerseits durch die Kommunikation, Kollaboration, die da stattfindet, aber eben auch von der Technik her, dass eben man auch mit seinem eigenen Computer sehr viel mehr Teil des Netzes wird, als das früher der Fall war. Also diese klare Trennung zwischen da ist das Netz und hier ist der Benutzer, das weicht halt in zunehmendem Maße auf. Insofern kann man auch Internet 2.0 zu sagen.
Aber um auf die Problematik mit der Bandbreite und dem Purismus zurückzukommen, die du angesprochen hast, natürlich ist es so, dass wenn man eine Sache einfach sagen kann, man es tun sollte. Und früher war das halt so, dass Bandbreite vielfach dazu benutzt wurde, Dinge unnötig aufzupeppen, die man ganz einfach sagen konnte. Wenn die Bandbreite aber nun mal da ist, dann sollte man sie nutzen. Und zum Beispiel im Beispiel von Filesharing, BitTorrent, hat das ja durchaus eine sogenannte, wie man so schön sagt, disruptive Wirkung. Die Bandbreite wird nämlich dazu genutzt, Informationen und Inhalte zu verteilen im Internet, die dort vorher so nicht verfügbar war. Es geht da so weniger um HTML mehr, sondern es geht darum, dass man eben komplexere Applikationen oder auch größere Inhalte hin und her schieben kann. Und das bringt mir ja was. Das ist ja was, was ich vorher so nicht machen konnte. Von daher ist die Bandbreite sinnvoll eingesetzt. Das ist kein Selbstzweck.
Also dieses Wort Bandbreitenverschwendung, das hab ich auch schon immer viel gehört. In Nerdkreisen wird das gerne verwendet. Ich mag das nicht. Ich würde eigentlich eher von einer Bandbreitennutzung sprechen wollen.
Aber UMTS wär schön, wenn sie mal verschwendet werden würden.
Wie der Einzelne das nutzt und wie man das jetzt selber sieht, das ist eine sehr persönliche Geschichte. Sollen die Leute doch mit dem Internet machen, was sie wollen, solange sie mich nicht zuspämmen, ist mir das eigentlich sogar ziemlich egal. Das tun sie natürlich auch und das ist auch ein anderes Problem. Aber ich sehe das nicht. Vor einigen Jahren wurde man ja noch, also einigen Jahren, die Abstände werden größer, aber vor zehn Jahren musste man sich ja noch anraunzen lassen, wenn man seine E-Mail verschickt hat und die Signature, also diese Standardanhang, die man noch an jedem E-Mail ranhängt, hat jetzt vier Zeilen überschritten. Dann kamen dann gleich irgendwelche Puritaner, die dir in dein Folge quarkt haben, ja, und deine Signature entspricht der Netiquette und Bandbreitenverschwendung und bla bla bla. Sicherlich war das ganz am Anfang, als wir alle nur langsame Modems hatten, ein Thema, aber das ist nun echt durch.
Ich glaube sogar die E-Mail Signature, das war der Beginn des Personal Publishing.
Ja, also wenn ich das jetzt richtig wahrnehme, dann sind also alle Gäste nach der Stimme zu urteilen, aus dem Team, ihr habt euch nie so ernst genommen, diesen Purismus. Also immer mit einem gesunden Menschenverstand aufgenommen.
Ja, ich meine aber, wenn man sich die ganzen neuen Websites anguckt von Web 2.0, die sind extrem, also die meisten sind sehr puristisch. Sie arbeiten mit Cascading Style Sheets, sie arbeiten sehr viel mit Wiederverwendung von Daten, sie sind sehr textbasiert, sie sind sehr clean. Also wenn so eine richtige Web 2.0 Website, wie man sie sehen würde, ist XHTML, Strikt, und die brauchen viel weniger Bandbreite, als die Sachen, die man vor ein paar Jahren gemacht hat. Was da Bandbreite schluckt, sind die Inhalte, also Videos und Bilder. Und das finde ich gar nicht so schlecht. Ich finde es schlimm, wenn man Bandbreite für sinnloses Zeug verschwendet, aber ich finde es gut, wenn die Leute sich austauschen und der Rahmen wenig Bandbreite braucht, aber die Inhalte, die können von mir aus so viel Bandbreite brauchen, wie sie wollen, wenn die Leute den Spaß dabei haben.
Da ich ein Open Source Container Management System mitentwickle, war ich ganz überrascht bei der Definition Web 0, was da eigentlich an Standards schon dazugehört, was zu Web 2.0 dazugehört, und was mich dann echt überrascht hat, dass ich eigentlich Web 2.0 schon längst nutze, ohne dass ich es weiß.
Was ist denn das für ein CMS?
Vorher hieß Marmo Open Source, jetzt heißt es Schumler. Und da trifft das durchaus zu, weil du gerade gesagt hast, es gibt die RSS-Feeds, es gibt die XML-Schnittstellen, jetzt mit der nächsten Version 1.5 kommen neue Schnittstellen hinzu. Migration ist ein Thema, wie kriege ich den Content aus einem CMS raus, wieder ins andere rein und so. Also da dürfte sich wirklich was in diese Richtung tun. Dass es einen Überbegriff hat, so art wie ein Hype.
Web 2.0 ist ein bisschen ein Gefühl, wenn man so will. Es ist eine Sammlung aus Technologien, Best Practices und Ideen. Wenn sich das einmal durchgesetzt hat, ist es sehr schön, weil was ich vorhin schon meinte, das Beispiel, man kann einfach sagen, mach das mal Web 2.0 und dann wird das irgendwie schön und sauber. Jeder kann sich ein bisschen was darunter vorstellen. Im Großen und Ganzen ist es nicht schlecht, was am Ende dabei rauskommt. Deswegen ist es auch ganz gut, dass da mal so ein Label draufgeklebt wurde.
Ja, aber man darf das nicht so ideologisch sehen. Web 2.0 ist halt einfach so ein Schlagwort im Moment. Und das ist auch der Grund, weshalb wir drüber reden und ein Sammelbegriff. Ja, es ist so eine Klammer.
Also wenn ich mir die ganzen Sachen durchgelesen hab, was so dazu gehört, dann kommt für mich so der Eindruck rüber, wenn man was festmachen will an Web 2.0, dann könnte man sagen, erst durch diese vielen Vereinfachungen des Standards, dass mehr Content, egal in welcher Form er ist, drüberbringt, dass es eigentlich mehr und mehr massentauglich ist. Auch Leute, das Internet eröffnet, das vorher eher durch die ganzen Technoiden und Nerdhaftigkeiten eher schwierigen Zugang hatten. Das würde zumindest die Popularität von Webblogs erklären, wobei ich glaube, hier niemand in der Runde sitzt, der gern Webblogs schreibt. Und ich glaube, viele Sachen dienen der Erleichterung, dass man das in Web nutzen kann. Also wenn ich irgendwann einen Sinn drin sehe, warum man einen Überbegriff, einen Metabegriff verwenden soll, dann würde ich das hier an der Sache festmachen. Ich grüße nochmal alle Runde und herzliche Grüße an Tim.
Ja, ich höre dir zu.
Dank nochmal, dass du in Wien warst aus der Easter Egg.
Ja, gerne. War ja auch eine tolle Veranstaltung.
Und ich hoffe, du kommst bald wieder nach Wien und alle anderen auch und zu uns auch ins Studio.
Vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Danke dir. Servus.
Ich wollte ganz kurz noch sagen, es ist eine Mail gekommen von Carsten. Ihr sprecht die ganze Zeit von Flickr. Wo finde ich denn das? Du hast Flickr mit E geschrieben. Das ist genau das Problem. Also flickr.com, also flickr.com. Dann findest du es ganz, ganz leicht. Es geht weiter mit Markus, 24 Jahre alt, aus Berlin, wenn das für dich okay ist.
Ich wollte noch mal kurz noch was nachschieben. Was dieses Web 2.0 ja auch bewirkt, ist ja im Prinzip eine Neuauflage dieser New Economy Phase. Also beflügelt nicht nur durch dieses Wort, aber letztlich auch, gibt es auch wieder ein neues Vertrauen der Investorengemeinde in neue Ideen. Also was wir vor einigen Jahren um 2000 herum hatten, mit dieser ganzen New Economy Blase, jeder konnte irgendwie eine verrückte Idee posten und bumm, hat er gleich 10 Millionen Kapital gehabt. So viel Kohle gibt es natürlich jetzt nicht mehr, aber die Bereitschaft steigt wieder, weil es wird sehr viel ausprobiert. Sehr viele dieser Web 2.0 Systeme werden einfach wieder unter diesem Gesichtspunkt betrachtet. Na, wer weiß, vielleicht fängt das irgendwie die Leute. Weil MySpace hatten wir schon genannt, und viele andere kleinere Webprojekte sind binnen kürzester Zeit unglaublich losgeschossen. Und da ist dann halt auch mal wieder eine Menge Geld zu verdienen, natürlich potentiell. Und auch da hat das einen großen Ausdruck.
Also sie sind ja nun auch schon verkauft worden. Also MySpace zum Beispiel ist glaube ich für 500 Millionen oder 580 Millionen an News Corp gegangen. Rupert Murdochs kleine News-Klitsche. Und man sagt jetzt schon, das wäre quasi so der Deal des Jahrzehnts gewesen, weil wie auch immer wie viele User sie jetzt haben, ob ein 70 oder 140 Millionen, Tatsache ist, da hat er sich eine sehr große Zielgruppe gekauft. Und man sieht ja, die Leute veröffentlichen da Musik. Es gibt auch schon die ersten Beispiele von Musikbands, die über MySpace das in die Charts geschafft haben. Delicious und Flickr, die beiden Beispiele, die wir vorhin genannt haben, da muss man vielleicht noch mal zu sagen, dass sie schon von Yahoo gekauft wurden. Und das befeuert natürlich die Sache enorm, dass natürlich die Pioniere dieser Technologie eben auch schon von den Großen als wichtig und richtig erkannt wurden und dann eben auch schon geschluckt wurden. Und gerade deswegen ist natürlich diese ganze Investmentmaschinerie, gerade in den USA, schon wieder auf Hochtouren, schon so sehr auf Hochtouren, dass einige Leute sagen, es ist schon wieder so eine Art kleine Blase.
Wollte ich gerade sagen, besteht da nicht schon wieder eine Gefahr, dass es sich wieder irgendwelche Menschen krallen, die damit Geld verdienen wollen?
Und ist das verboten?
Ich denke, die Gefahr besteht immer. Aber es gibt natürlich einen großen Unterschied, wenn man an 2000 denkt oder an, ich meine, der erste Absturz in der New Economy war ja BuCom. Solche Partyfirmen, die gibt es heute nicht mehr. Zum einen brauchen wir nicht so wahnsinnig viel Geld, um was zu machen. Früher hatten wir ein Content-Management-System für 100.000 kaufen müssen und eine Oracle-Datenbank und mussten sich irgendwelche sehr, sehr teuren Leute einstellen. Heute kann jede kleine Gruppe von Leuten hingehen, die ein bisschen coden können, ein paar Ideen haben und können relativ schnell was auf die Beine stellen.
Man sieht dann auch, ob es funktioniert oder nicht.
Man sieht sofort, ob es funktioniert und deshalb heißen diese Dienste, die es neu gibt, die sind ja alle Beta. Beta ist so ein in der EDF Order Begriff für Dinge, die noch nicht ganz fertig sind, aber schon ganz gut. Und diese Systeme sind alle Beta. Man stellt was auf die Beine, stellt es online und guckt, was die Leute damit machen. Und dann guckt man, was man für Feedback bekommt und passt das System immer mehr so an, dass die User sagen, hier, da fühle ich mich wohl, da kann ich was damit anfangen. Und das kann man heute mit sehr, sehr wenig Geld machen. Das ist überhaupt nicht vergleichbar wie in der New Economy Hype. Deshalb wird auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel investiert in Beträgen. Und deshalb wird wahrscheinlich im Endeffekt für irgendwelche... Also was heute gar nicht mehr läuft, ist, dass eine Firma sagt, ich habe hier ein Konzept und ich bin ein cooler Typ und ich will mal 10 Millionen. Jemand, der Geld investiert, wird sagen, wenn du ein cooler Typ bist, dann machst du das doch erst mal. Und wenn es einigermaßen läuft, dann geben wir dir vielleicht auch Geld.
Macht es abends, macht es am Wochenende.
Macht es nachts. Und wenn das dann läuft, so haben die Services angefangen. Und dann hat so ein Blicker angefangen, delicious hat Joshua Schecter abends nachts allein neben seinem Fulltime-Job gemacht. So ähnlich wie ICQ war aus dem Beispiel.
Er hat seinen Fulltime-Job eigentlich erst aufgegeben, drei Monate bevor er von Yahoo! Also er hat es fast geschafft, ohne einen Fulltime-Job von Yahoo! gekauft zu werden.
Deshalb ist der...
Man braucht ein Proof of Concept, dass Concept alleine reicht.
Und es gibt natürlich noch einen ganz, ganz fundamentalen Unterschied. Und der ist, dass diese Firmen wie Amazon, Google, eBay, Yahoo! natürlich inzwischen reales und massives Geld verdienen. Also damals war das so, dass diese Firmen gerade selber noch damit gestruggelt haben. Die waren schon defizitär, sie hatten eine gewisse Größe, aber sie haben eigentlich noch gar kein Geld verdient, als die Blase dann letztlich geplatzt ist. Und sich darauf zu verlassen, dass eine Firma die Verluste schreibt, einen irgendwann kauft, das ist natürlich schwierig. Und heutzutage ist es so, dass also dabei der Online-Werbemarkt ja schon massiv gewachsen ist. Also viele von den Dingen, die man damals vorhergesagt hat, auch finanzieller Natur und was die Wachstumsraten und die Verdienstmöglichkeiten angeht, sind ja dann letzten Endes auch wirklich so eingetreten. Das heißt, da steckt jetzt schon eine andere Substanz dahinter. Also Yahoo, Google, Amazon, Ebay und die Großen, die werden sicherlich nie wieder pleite gehen. Im Gegenteil.
Deshalb kann man nur alle aufrufen.
Na ja, was heißt nie wieder? Aber es ist ja ein Jahr in absehbarer Zeit.
Ja, aber deshalb, gerade was Web 2.0 angeht und was Mesh-Up und diese Freiheit angeht, Dinge zu tun, kann man eigentlich nur jeden aufrufen, der Lust hat, was zu machen, dass er sich ein paar Leute sucht oder das allein macht und einfach mal seine Ideen umsetzt. Und was macht man? Man kann billig Web Space kaufen, die Technologien sind alle da, man kann sie schnell erlernen. Und wie gesagt, jeder kann was machen und jeder sollte auch was machen, wenn er eine gute Idee hat.
Es gibt inzwischen ja ning.com zum Beispiel, das ist ein schönes Beispiel auch, von dem Marc Andresen, der seinerzeit Mosaik programmiert hat und dann Netscape an die Börse gebracht hat. Der hat jetzt eine neue Geschichte, die heißt ning.com. Die ist nichts anderes als ein MySpace zum Zusammenklicken. Da kann ich mir also ein sogenanntes Social Network oder so soziale Applikationen einfach zusammenklicken. Und der zusätzliche Twist daran ist, wenn ich auf einer Seite bin, die sich jemand zusammengeklickt und zusammengebaut hat, dann ist da ein kleiner Button, der heißt Clone This. Und dann kann ich also genau das, wie er es genommen hat, nehmen und kann es einfach weiterentwickeln. Das heißt, das wird immer einfacher. Und wenn ich eine gute Idee hab, dann hakt es nicht mehr an der Technik. Ich brauch eigentlich gar nicht mehr programmieren, um was Gutes zu machen.
Im Chat wird schon Basswort Bingo gespielt, hab ich den Eindruck hier. Wollen wir gleich mal einen Begriff erklären, den wir gerade fallen gelassen haben. Mesh-ups, das ist ein interessantes Phänomen. Mesh-up, meines Wissens wurde es zuerst für Musik verwendet, aber gilt jetzt eben auch im Web als so ein Ansatz. Man muss sich gar nicht mehr alles selber zusammen programmieren, sondern viele dieser Dienste stehen nicht nur unter ihrem eigenen Domain bereit, sondern man kann die wie eine Komponente auch mit einbauen. Das plakativste Beispiel ist sicherlich Google Maps. Das haben wir schon wieder Google gesagt. Hier hat vorhin schon einer gesagt, es geht hier eigentlich nur noch um Google. Ist Google Web 2.0? Aber Google spielt das Spiel natürlich sehr gut. Von daher taugen sie häufig als Beispiel. Google Maps sind halt diese Landkarten, Satellitenbilder, Luftbilder und auch Straßenkarten im Internet. Die kann man nicht nur auf der Site Maps google.com klicken, sondern man kann als Entwickler von einer Webseite das auch einbauen. Es wäre vielleicht auch mal eine Gelegenheit, mal euer Projekt kurz auch noch mal mit reinzubringen. Ihr seid ja auch fleißig am Hacken und habt hier in Berlin eine Bude aufgezogen, die im Prinzip eigentlich auch unter Web 2.0 fällt. Kann man so sagen, oder? Heißt places.com, plazis.com. Vielleicht könntest du es mal kurz selbst vorstellen.
Places ist im Endeffekt ein Lokalisierungsservice. Das heißt, ich bin dort, wo mein Netzwerk ist. Wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel auf Places geht und man würde mich suchen, dann würde man dort sehen, dass ich mich beim Chaosradio befinde. Und man sieht auch automatisch, wer da noch online ist. Ein großer Aspekt, und dann kann man eben so schöne Sachen machen, wie wer ist eigentlich in meiner Nähe und welche Leute waren hier vorher schon beim Chaosradio gewesen. Und was gibt es sonst noch für Orte um mich herum. Und da zum Beispiel haben wir, als wir das ursprünglich gebaut haben, haben wir das ohne Karten gemacht. Weil Karten selber zu bauen, das konnten wir uns nicht leisten. Wir haben das eben selbst am Abend oder am Wochenende gemacht. Stefan hat das zu weit gehen, komplett selbst programmiert. Das heißt, am Anfang war das ziemlich langweilig, weil wir reden über Orte und wir reden über Adressen und wir reden über Positionen und man kann es nicht auf der Karte sehen. Und dann plötzlich irgendwann letzten Sommer kam Google Maps raus. Und zwar nicht einfach nur Google Maps, sondern eben auch die API, die Programmierschnittstelle, mit der man eben diese Karten in seine eigenen Dienste einbauen kann. Und schwuppdiwupp haben wir unsere Datenbank genommen mit den ganzen Orten und den ganzen Adressen und Positionen, den Geokoordinaten da drin. Und konnten plötzlich alles auf einer Karte darstellen. Und plötzlich war vielen Leuten klar, ah, das ist also Places. Und das macht ja jetzt viel mehr Spaß. Und jetzt kapiere ich es endlich. Und das war was, was wir uns so gar nicht hätten selber leisten können. Und wir geben dann eben auch wieder was zurück, indem wir dann unsererseits wieder eine Programmierschnittstelle anbieten. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt gerade die neue API released, da kommt man dann also wirklich auch an unsere Daten ran. Das heißt, wenn jemand jetzt ein kleines Spiel machen möchte, ein Spiele-Spiel, ein Spiele-Spiel, ein Spiele-Spiel, ein Spiele-Spiel, ein Spiele-Spiel.
Ein Spiele-Spiel, ein Spiele-Spiel, ein Spiele-Spiel, ein Spiele-Spiel, ein Spiele-Spiel, ein Spiele-Spiel, ein Spiele-Spiel, ein Spiele-Spiel, ein Spiele-Spiel, ein Spiele-Spiel, ein Spiele-Spiel, ein.
Das ist so ein Beispiel.
Mitternacht noch eine Stunde Chaos Radio mit ganz vielen Gästen, die sich alle noch mal ganz kurz selbst vorstellen. Das finde ich schön.
Echt? Ja.
Ich bin Tim.
Ich bin Stefan.
Ich bin Felix und ich bin Markus. Es ist immer nämlich etwas besser, dann irgendwann die Stimmen zu zuordnen.
Und das ist Sprechprobe für die automatische Sprechererkennung. Genau.
Markus, 24 Jahre alt, aus Berlin. Hallo. Was wolltest du loswerden?
Ich wollte mal was zur Informationsdarstellung und Informationsveröffentlichung in dem ganzen Web 2.0-Thema sagen. Wir haben vorhin schon mal darüber gesprochen. Ich finde es ganz interessant, dass das noch irgendwie noch nicht so richtig zur Sprache gekommen ist, dass ich ja, wenn ich jetzt Informationen irgendwo eintrage, trotzdem in der Initialveröffentlichung, sage ich mal, trotzdem noch der Herr dieser Informationen bin. Also ich kann meinetwegen alle meine Daten irgendwo eintragen. Ich kann einen Namen eintragen, ich kann einen Ort eintragen, ich kann meine Hobbys, meine sonst was, meine Freunde, meine Freundin, den Namen von meinem Hund, was meine Großmutter am liebsten ist und meine Jobs und wie blöd mein Chef ist reinhauen. Aber im Prinzip weiß es nicht jeder, welche Daten davon relevant sind. Also wenn ich weiß, dass Felix zum Beispiel beim Chaos Radio sitzt, weiß ich das, weil ich ihn zum Beispiel kenne. Aber er könnte auch oder ich könnte auch einfach irgendeine andere Information reinschreiben. Und dieser soziale Filter, der jeder Mensch, jede Person ja selber ist, filtert dann diese Information raus. Also wenn er sagt, hey, ich bin in den USA zum Beispiel, dann weiß ich, dass es nicht stimmt. Ja, weil ich kenne ihn halt. Und das ist immer so ein heikles Ding irgendwie. Es wird immer gesagt, ja klar, alle Daten sind crawlbar, Google crawlt alle Daten, die ich irgendwie mal veröffentlicht habe. Aber im Prinzip ist es für die nur Machine Code. Also wenn ich es drauf anlege, könnte ich vollkommen eine Fakes einfach einsetzen. Und die würden dann auch genauso bei Google als Ergebnis auftauchen.
Ich finde es einen sehr interessanten Aspekt, weil im Endeffekt ist es den Wald vor lauter Bäumen nicht sehen. Das heißt, was du meinst, ist man könnte Bots los schicken, die im Endeffekt lauter Fehlinformationen über mich verbreiten und durch mein Social Network könnte ich es so filtern, dass ich sehen kann, was stimmen kann und was nicht.
Ja klar, ich kann Google auch vollspammen. Also auf der anderen Seite von unten. Und wenn du es halt so anlegst, dass das meinetwegen jeder das machen könnte, dann kommt es wieder dahin zurück. Was wichtig ist nämlich, dass deine sozialen Beziehungen einfach wichtig werden. Also wer dich kennt, weiß welche dieser Informationen wahr ist und zutreffend ist. Und dann kann Google und Amazon noch so viel crawlen, die werden es irgendwie wahrscheinlich nicht rausfinden.
Also wie Ironie, ohne Kontext verstehe ich sie nicht.
Jaja, genau so ungefähr.
Und daher finde ich diese ganze Panikmache, die teilweise auch abgeht. Also keine Frage, Datenschutz ist extrem wichtig. Aber in diesem ganzen Web 2.0 Kontext entscheide ich initiativ trotzdem immer noch selber, was ich eigentlich das erste Mal veröffentliche, bevor ich irgendwas, bevor ich irgendwie gecrawlt werde oder gescannt oder getrackt werde oder sonst was. Und das finde ich ist eigentlich eine ganz faire Sache. Außerdem ist es halt eine Frage, wer wie Daten sammelt. Also kritisch ist es, wenn es halt an einer Stelle ist und ich kann nicht selber kontrollieren, welche Daten von mir gesammelt werden.
Hast du denn schon mal persönliche Erfahrungen gemacht, negativer Art?
Negativ ehrlich gesagt nicht, nee, was habe ich mal?
Also Dinge, die du veröffentlicht hast und die später auf dich zurückgefallen sind in irgendeiner Form?
Ja klar, also ich habe mal bei Flickr so ein bisschen ironisches Bildchen mit so einem Don Alfonso Bezug reingestellt. Klar, es hat dann natürlich auch irgendeine Diskussion genau über dieses Thema losgetreten. Das ist dann hieß ja, du haust alle deine Daten raus und du bist ein Idiot und wie kann man nur? Und wir sehen, wo du arbeitest und wir sehen, wo du wohnst und so und so. Ich weiß wo du wohnst. Ich weiß wo du wohnst Alter und ich ruf mal deinen Chef an und sag dem mal, was du für ein Idiot bist und so. Aber naja, mein Gott, also das sind jetzt keine Sachen, die irgendwie negativ auf mich zurückgefallen wären. Was ganz interessant dabei war, ist, dass diese Leute, denen ich bestimmt unterstelle, dass sie nur das Beste für meine Daten und für meine Persönlichkeitsrechte wollten, im Prinzip genau das machen, wofür sie propagieren, nämlich Daten veröffentlichen. Also Daten von mir veröffentlichen, also Raussuchen von mir veröffentlichen, die ich halt nicht autorisiert habe oder so. Ist jetzt auch nicht weiter schlimm, weil ich es an anderer Stelle wahrscheinlich trotzdem irgendwo mal gemacht habe. Aber das ist schon eine Sache, die mir dann aufgefallen ist. Da ist das Ja hier und dann man kriegt da deinen Klarnamen raus und der ist übrigens so und so.
Ja gut, ich meine, wenn du es veröffentlicht hast, dann muss man natürlich damit rechnen, dass andere Leute das aufgreifen.
Klar, aber dafür mache ich es ja. Also es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass ich irgendwas ins Internet stelle und sage, hey, hoffentlich sieht es keiner. Also das muss halt klar sein, wir haben ja vorhin schon mal drüber geredet, dass du Sachen, die einmal online sind und einmal im Google Cache sind, einfach schwer wieder loskriegst. Die sind halt erstmal da drin.
Also du, ich weiß nicht, ob ich deinen Punkt jetzt richtig verstehe. Du meinst, es ist zu viel Paranoia am Werk oder?
Ich meine, es ist viel Paranoia am Werk. Ich bin durchaus dafür, dass man diese ganzen Datenspeicherungen und so, dass man das durchaus kritisch sieht. Aber ich sehe auch, ich empfinde es, dass das viel Paranoia am Werk ist und dass viel auch einfach schlecht geredet wird, indem man sagt, ja, das sind wieder irgendwelche Daten-Nazis am Werk.
Na ja, also man darf es halt nicht aus dem, ich meine, es gibt ja diesen schönen Satz, nur weil ich paranoid bin, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass sie nicht auch hinter mir her sind. Was heute noch nicht kritisch erscheinen kann, morgen schon eine wertvolle Information sein. Und ich meine, wir sind eigentlich beim Chaosradio, haben wir eigentlich schon immer auch diesen Punkt vertreten, das mag ja sein, dass du der Meinung bist, du hättest nichts zu verbergen, aber du weißt ja auch überhaupt gar nicht, was alles an Daten für dich überhaupt anfällt. Und von daher, man muss es schon im Hinterkopf haben. Auf der anderen Seite stimme ich dir auch total zu. Eine gewisse optimistische Herangehensweise ist auch förderlich, weil wenn man sich jetzt nur im Kopf immer wieder verblockt und so und aha, und das ist ja dieses und jenes und lalala und kein Vertrauen damit reinbringt, dann funktioniert es auch nicht. Und ich denke, das zeigt auch, dass so viele Leute dem doch relativ aufgeschlossen gegenüberstehen, dass das auch vorherrscht.
Also ich hatte eher den Eindruck, also ich weiß gar nicht, wie das war, Stefan oder Felix, man hat schon irgendwie ein schlechtes Gefühl im Hinterkopf, lässt sich aber davon nicht abhalten.
Ja, weil ja auch andere Sachen zählen. Es zählt die Convenience und es zählt halt auch dieses entweder ich kann es überhaupt machen oder gar nicht so und ja, die Entscheidung muss natürlich jeder für sich selber fällen, aber ich kann nur dafür plädieren, dass man eben auch den anderen Aspekt nicht aus dem Kopf nimmt.
Es gibt vor allem einen Aspekt, wo es dann natürlich noch mal eine ganze Ecke kritischer wird. Das eine ist, jemand kennt meinen Namen und googelt den und surft ein bisschen rum, sagen wir mal der Personalchef und erfährt ein paar Dinge über mich. Die andere Geschichte ist natürlich, dass wir auch, das hat auch was mit Web 2.0 zu tun, in Richtung von Syndikationsformaten, Stichwort RSS oder so was wie Microformats gehen. Das heißt eben auch, die Maschinenlesbarkeit von Dingen eine Rolle spielt. Da gab es, glaube ich, mal vom CCC auch einen schönen, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das ein Vortrag war oder so. Es hieß, glaube ich, geheimdienstliche Methoden der Informationskombination. Das heißt, man kann mit frei verfügbaren Daten, natürlich durch die Kombination, durch Kreuzreferenzierung, durch Abgleich, natürlich eine ganze Menge mehr rauskriegen. Ich glaube, am Ende kam dann raus, dass man sehen konnte, in welchem Haus was gewählt wurde oder so. Also das geht relativ, da geht unheimlich viel. Und das waren damals, ich glaube, man hat das auch so Telefonbuch, CDs und so extrahiert. Und da sind natürlich jetzt plötzlich ganz andere Möglichkeiten gegeben. Und dann wird es natürlich wiederum interessant, wenn ich sagen kann, ich suche nicht manuell nach jemandem, sondern da läuft jemand, läuft eine Maschine los, die alles ständig monitort, was zu meinem Namen passiert. Und das vielleicht noch mit anderen Informationsquellen abgleicht. Das ist schon eine Geschichte. Das ist sicherlich ein Problem, da muss man auf Dauer drüber reden, im Zusammenhang mit solchen Geschichten wie Microformats. Also ich meine, viele Leute stellen ihre E-Mail-Adresse eben nicht auf die Seite, damit sie eben nicht gehavestet werden kann und plötzlich sind diese Informationen wieder sehr frei und sehr schön lesbar verfügbar. Das ist sicherlich ein Thema, wo man neben vielen Guten auch noch viele Probleme haben wird.
Das ist eh lustig, ich stehe seit zehn Jahren nicht mehr im Telefonbuch, aber im Web findet man alles raus.
Und du fühlst dich immer noch gut dabei, jedes Mal zu sagen, nein, ich möchte nicht gelistet sein.
Markus, Dankeschön. Wenn ihr Fragen habt oder was zum Thema sagen wollt, ruft einfach an 0331 70 97 110.
Jetzt wartet erst mal keiner mehr.
Jetzt wartet keiner.
Ja, ich wollte mal hier kurz auf die Fragen eingehen. Wir haben ja immer so diese begleitende Seite in der Wikipedia der Sendung und haben sich eine ganze Menge Fragen angereichert. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob wir die Gelegenheit haben, das alles durchzugehen, aber vielleicht nagen wir mal das eine oder andere an, das ist jetzt nicht besonders sortiert, aber ich gehe es einfach mal von oben durch. Eine Frage ist jetzt hier, inwieweit die Web 2.0 Browser Techniken, die Sache mit dem Backbutton, ja, das ist schon mit der Navigation. Also dadurch, dass man jetzt so einen intelligenten, die Möglichkeit hat, die Inhalte einer Seite zu ändern, ohne dass sich oben die URL ändert, gibt es immer so ein bisschen die Angst, dass es dann so mit diesem schönen Vorwärts-Rückwärts-Bericht. Aber eigentlich ist es besser geworden.
Ja, ich denke, das ist eine Frage des Seitenparadigmas. Wenn ich jetzt bei Applikationen drin bin, die alles für mich übernimmt und so agiert wie eine lokale Testdruck-Applikation, also ich würde nie auf die Idee kommen, in meinem Word oder so auf den Backbutton zu klicken.
Aber schön wäre, ja. Ich merke, haben das verschiedene Applikationen, ich finde das angenehm, ein Feind da.
Also wenn ich so eine Applikation habe, dann ist es vielleicht gegen den Reflex. Wenn ich den Reflex habe, immer dieses Stop-Load-Paradigma, also Eingabe, Seite wird neu geladen, Eingabe, Seite wird neu geladen. Wenn ich dann den Reflex habe, zurückzugehen oder so, dann ist es schlecht.
Gut, da gibt es Ctrl-Z.
Ja, das ist aber wieder was anderes als der Backbutton.
Aber der Wikipedia zum Beispiel würde das ganz gut tun, so ein bisschen Ajax. Weil wenn man da eine Seite bearbeitet, dann hat man halt in seiner Browser-Historie dann auch mal so diese Edit-Seiten, dann geht man irgendwie zurück und dann ist man wieder im Editor und es ist alles total unklar.
Und so denke ich, da wo der Backbutton Sinn macht, wenn man Seiten anguckt, wenn man Seiten blättert, da ist er sicherlich sinnvoll, aber bei den Applikationen nicht. Und ich denke, wenn die Applikation sich so darstellt, also wie ein Mailprogramm oder wie was anderes, und es so gut macht, dann wird man vielleicht von selbst gar nicht auf die Idee kommen, den Backbutton zu drücken. Aber klar ist ein Paradigmenwechsel, weil der Browser, ich meine das Ding, ist mein Mikrofon weg?
Jetzt klingt irgendwas toller.
Irgendwas auf einmal klingst du toll, ohne dass ich irgendwas hier veränderte. Ich kling toll.
Ja, Wahnsinn.
Weniger Echo.
Das freut mich natürlich. Das Browser heißt ja auch Blätterer. Und wenn man jetzt eine Applikation im Browser ausführt, dann ist der Blätterer vielleicht nicht mehr das richtige Werkzeug.
Dann gibt es hier noch die Frage, die finde ich auch ganz interessant, nach dem WebOS. Das ist eigentlich eine relativ frische Diskussion, wenn ich das richtig mitverfolge. Also nicht, dass die Frage schon lange gestellt wurde, aber so inwieweit kann denn der Browser dann auch wirklich die Alternative sein zum Betriebssystem? Also inwieweit ist die Web-Applikation dann auch die Alternative? Tja, WebOS, ich glaube, dass das noch eine Weile dauern wird, aber was sich auf jeden Fall jetzt schon abzeichnet, ist durch diese unglaublich umfangreiche Verwendung von JavaScript und den Entwicklung von neuen, interessanten Anwendungen, die im Browser laufen, wird sich über kurz oder lang so ein Weg entwickeln, erst mal über Frameworks, das heißt viele Sachen, die jetzt von jedem noch komplett neu programmiert werden, werden dann erst mal durch populäre Frameworks abgelöst. Da gibt es schon so den Trends, gibt es die ersten Bibliotheken, wo die Leute halt einfach sagen, ok bevor ich das alles nochmal neu hacke, probierst du auch mal damit. Und dann habe ich auch den Vorteil, dass mir dann eben auch Arbeit abgenommen wird. Und sowas könnte mittelfristig auch zu so etwas wie einem Webbetriebssystem führen. Das ist glaube ich etwas schwer Vorhersagbares. Aber ich würde mich auch nicht wundern, wenn wir schon im nächsten Jahr da was Substantielles vorfinden würden.
Ja gut, der Trend geht sicherlich in die Richtung. Also ursprünglich war das Netz die Transportschicht. Das heißt, ich hatte sowohl Logik als auch die Daten bei mir lokal auf der Kiste. Und dann habe ich diese eine E-Mail, die wir bei mir lokal genommen, habe die übers Internet übertragen und dann hat die jemand anders wieder auf seine Kiste gezogen. Da sind wir jetzt schon einen Schritt weiter. Also das heißt, es wird nicht nur als Transportschicht, als Telefonleitung genutzt, sondern es wird auch eben schon für das Speichern von Daten verwandt. Und jetzt sehen wir halt langsam, dass es auch dafür verwandt wird, die Logik, die ich vorher lokal hatte, ins Netz zu bringen. Also sowas wie Flickr ist ja auch ein Beispiel. Ich hatte vorher eben mein Bildverwaltungsprogramm wie iPhoto lokal. Das habe ich vielleicht immer noch, aber zusätzlich habe ich Flickr. Und diese, wenn auch zugegebenermaßen recht geringe Logik, die ist jetzt schon ins Web gewandert. Und das werden wir sicherlich in Zukunft noch mehr sehen, glaube ich.
Wobei da natürlich noch viele Sachen geklärt werden müssen. Da haben wir ja vorher schon drüber gesprochen, also der Datenschutz, Sicherheit. Nicht nur der Betreiber dieser Applikation kann meine Daten lesen, sondern ich verschicke halt einfach Sachen über den Datenstrom, die irgendjemand mitlesen kann. Und das sind halt alles Fragen, die dann noch geklärt werden müssen. Und deshalb fängt man natürlich mit E-Mail an, weil das ist eh schon im Netz. Und nach und nach werden halt andere Sachen kommen.
Ich hätte jetzt noch einen Anrufer, und zwar Matthias, 28 Jahre alt, aus Finsterwalde.
Guten Morgen.
Hallo.
Guten Abend oder guten Morgen, wie man es möchte. Guten Morgen.
Hat dir der Begriff Web 2.0 vorher schon was gesagt?
Überhaupt nicht, muss ich zugeben. Und zwar auf die Bemerkung...
Sagte dir denn jetzt schon was?
Ja, ich hab, wie gesagt, auf Anregung des einen Hörers, dann auch direkt mal die Wikipedia angeworfen, mich mal ein bisschen belesen. Im Prinzip ist es genauso, wie es halt dort beschrieben ist, dass solche Services sind, die halt so nach und nach sich ins alltägliche Internetgeschehen eingeschränkt haben, die man dann halt nutzt oder auch nicht. Und man hat es halt assimiliert, sag ich mal, ohne mitzubekommen oder über diesen Begriff Web 2.0 dort zu stolpern. Bloß auf die Bemerkung hin des einen Hörers oder des einen Kollegen von meinem Studio dort, ob man ein schlechtes Gewissen haben sollte oder muss, wenn man solche Services nicht intensiv nutzt. Da habe ich mich direkt ad hapt gefühlt. Ich habe den Namen vorher nicht ganz mitbekommen, wo man angeblich angemeldet werden muss als drittst frequentiertes Service im Netz im Moment. Wie hieß das vorhin?
Was ist das, will ich mal fragen. Also muss gar nicht. Also so würde man das nicht sagen. myspace.com meinst du wahrscheinlich. Also wo so viele Leute jetzt ihre Homepage da austoben.
Also ist das einfach eine modernere Form von Beep World oder wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Es ist eine modernere Form von, bietet dir alles, was man so gemeinhin braucht. Also ist insbesondere geeignet für Leute, die halt auch ihre Musik veröffentlichen wollen, weil halt da so der Musikplayer gleich mit drin ist. Ich habe jetzt selber noch nicht so viel mit MySpace gearbeitet, deswegen kann ich über die Bedienbarkeit des Systems nichts sagen, aber es haben jetzt schon Freunde von mir dort Seiten eingerichtet, die bis vor kurzem noch komplett webagnostisch waren.
Man kann halt auch so seine Charts einstellen, auch wenn da gar nicht die Musik dahinter steht und dadurch kommen auch ganz schnell Sachen hoch, so innerhalb von irgendwelchen DJs, aha, der hört jetzt gerade Dis und dann höre ich mir das auch mal an. Diese Dinge sind sehr beschleunigt.
Verstehe, der Player leitet sozusagen auch gleich die Hörgewohnheiten weiter. Ja, also das ist auf jeden Fall so eine der populäreren Sachen. Was ich persönlich sehr schön finde und wo man mal drüber nachdenken sollte, das vielleicht zu verwenden, das ist halt Delicious. Das ist eine etwas kompliziertere URL, deswegen sollte man sie vielleicht auch nochmal durchsagen. Das ist del.ico.us, also del.ico.us, delicious. Und dieser Social Bookmark Manager, der macht Spaß und ist auf jeden Fall super. StumbleUpon und es gibt auch noch shadows.com. Also es gibt eine ganze Batterie von diesen Diensten und das mischt sich. Google spielt da jetzt auch demnächst mit, glaube ich, in diesem Bookmark-Spielchen. Also es gibt mehr als man er tragen kann.
Mehr als er tragen, das ist richtig. Ich halte ja solche Bookmark-Management-Systeme extrem sinnvoll. Bei solchen Geschichten, wo halt die User dort privat ihren Krempeel, sage ich jetzt mal, ohne das abwerten zu wollen, veröffentlichen. Ich halte das irgendwie wirklich eine Verlagerung des sozialen Aspekts in diese Anonymität Internet rein.
Also so anonym ist es ja nicht, haben wir ja gerade festgestellt. Das ist ja eher das Gegenteil von Anonymität.
Also ich denke, das Internet wird halt einfach ein Teil des Lebens. Ich meine, solange die Leute nicht nur noch zu Hause sitzen und chatten, sondern sich vielleicht auch mal irgendwo treffen, oder in der Kneipe und so, ist es eine sehr, sehr sinnvolle Sache.
Nee, aber ich glaube, was Matthias meint, ist, also jetzt gehen wir mal in Zeiten zurück, wo es kein Internet gab, einfach ein paar Jahrzehnte zurück. Wenn jemand seine Urlaubsfotos einfach an die Litwa-Säule geklebt hätte. Meintest du das?
Ja, im Prinzip in dem Sinne, erstens in dem Sinne, dass halt, ich könnte mich nicht erinnern, dass irgendjemand seine Urlaubsfotos unbedingt an die Litwa-Säule geklebt hätte.
Aber was die Leute gemacht haben, sie haben ganz viele Abzüge gemacht für all ihre Verwandten.
Ja, da ist es halt.
Dann sind es aber genau die Leute, die man halt sowieso aus seinem Leben kannte, mit denen man auch persönlich, und das meinte ich jetzt, ich meinte jetzt vielleicht nicht in dem Sinne anonymen das Internet, sondern eher abstrakter halt. Nicht die Leute aus dem persönlichen Umfeld, sondern das kann dann halt auch der...
Aus dem Privaten in die Öffentlichkeit.
Richtig, und das kann dann halt auch der Chatpartner in Amiland sein oder so.
Ich glaube halt, dass das nie das primäre Motiv ist, oder das erste Motiv, ein Foto online zu stellen, damit alle sehen. Vielleicht schon, ja, aber in den meisten Fällen, vor allem bei diesen Foto-Sharing-Diensten, das hat Stefan vorhin schon ganz richtig erwähnt, die erfolgreichen Dienste, die erfüllen erst mal ein egoistisches Bedürfnis. Also ich will meine Bookmarks speichern und ich will sie vielleicht so speichern, dass ich sie immer wieder finde und dass sie quasi immer da sind und nicht, wenn ich meinen Rechner neu installiere, schon wieder weg sind oder ich wechsle meinen Browser, muss die importieren, exportieren. Das Gleiche gilt für Fotos. Ich will die an einem Ort haben und ich will vor allem, und das kennt glaube ich jeder, wenn er, sobald er sich so eine Digitalknipse gekauft hat, möchte er, dass andere Leute die Sachen natürlich auch sehen. Und das sind durchaus Leute, die man kennt. Also ich habe letztes Wochenende was unternommen, das Kegelverein, dann möchte ich natürlich, dass meine Kegelbrüder dann auch auf diese Bilder zugreifen können. Und das ist glaube ich das Motiv. Und dann darüber hinaus, dass es so viele Leute tun, wird halt noch ein Zusatznutzen erzeugt. Eben durch diese Tags, über die wir vorhin geredet haben, dass man halt sagen kann, na ja, wenn ich jetzt nach Bildern von Berlin suche, dann kann ich mal von allem profitieren, was die Leute so eingestellt haben und kann halt alle Berlin-Bilder sehen. Ich glaube, das primäre Motiv ist eigentlich immer egoistische Natur, jedenfalls bei erfolgreichen Diensten. Sie erfüllen erst mal Bedarf.
Ja, und bei Myspace, bei der Selbstdarstellung ist es halt so, ich meine, ein Teenager verbringt auch jeden Morgen eine halbe Stunde vom Spiegel, um sein Outfit fit zu machen. Und so sitzt er halt noch mal abends zwei Stunden, um sein Myspace-Profil besser zu machen.
Und bei Myspace ist es auch so, dass die ersten Soziologen, die sich damit beschäftigen, es gibt ja auch schon welche, die das tun, eben festgestellt haben, dass die meisten Leute ihren realen Freundeskreis einfach ins Netz übertragen. Also zum Beispiel die Teenager, die das groß gemacht haben, Myspace, amerikanische Teenager, die hängen halt vormittags mit irgendwelchen Freunden ab und nachmittags hängen sie mit den gleichen Freunden aus der Schule auf Myspace ab. Und es ist eben nicht so, dass da irgendein beliebiger 40-Jähriger aus Deutschland kommt und mal eben die 16-Jährige aus den USA anspricht und die dann sofort oder mit völlig unterschiedlichen sozialen Backgrounds sofort ins Gespräch kommen.
Ja, aber es war jetzt in der Diskussion die letzte Woche, dass sich vorbestrafte Sexualstraftäter bei Myspace Profile anlegen und sich dort irgendwie gut darstellen und dass da große Früchte vorherrscht. Also es ist schon gefährlich. Also ich glaube, da haben wir ja vorher schon drüber gesprochen, diese Eigenverantwortung, seine Inhalte auch bewusst zu veröffentlichen und zu sagen, okay, meine Familienfoto, die sieht halt nur meine Familie oder meine engsten Freunde und die anderen Sachen, die zeige ich da nicht. Das müssen die Leute schon lernen. Und ich gehe davon aus, dass sie das tun werden.
Da will ich kurz noch mal einhaken. Diese Sexualstraftäter-Geschichte, das sind zwei Sachen. Einerseits gibt es die, die sich bei MySpace so und so zeigen. Dann gibt es aber auch noch die Sexualstraftäter, die mal welche waren, die verurteilt wurden, die dann von jemand anders erschossen wurden, weil sie halt irgendwie vom Staat wegpolitiert wurden. Das gibt es in beide Richtungen. Bevor hier gleich wieder die große Angstdiskussion aufflattert, muss man sagen, die jungen Leute heute haben eine viel größere Medienkompetenz, was Chats und solche Homepage-Geschichten betrifft. Die glauben halt auch nicht alles. Also dieses Vertrauen in die Daten, ich glaube, das ist eine sehr naive Sicht. Ich würde schon dem erfahrenen Benutzer, und erfahren ist man halt, umso jünger man ist, umso schneller geht das auch, dem würde ich schon zutrauen, dass er das eben auch selber bewerten kann. Und das ist eigentlich auch das, was man sich erarbeitet. Man muss sich immer Medienkompetenz erarbeiten, um mit diesen Technologien umzugehen. Das war eigentlich auch mit dem Telefon nicht anders. Und jetzt ist es halt beim Internet eine andere Komplexität.
Früher haben die Erwachsenen halt den Kindern beigebracht, keine Schokolade anzunehmen von irgendwelchen fremden Onkels. Und heute bringen die Kinder den Vätern bei, doch bitte nicht auf irgendwelche VEGA-Agramme jetzt zu klicken.
Okay, aber Matthias, du hattest gar nicht die Sicherheitsbedenken, nur das mehr die Bedenken, dass das Privat öffentlich wird? Oder was hat dich jetzt bewegt?
Nee, nee, das spielt alles ineinander. Einmal halt diese doch recht schonungslose Offenlegung des Privatnehmens, sag ich jetzt mal durchaus so, weil wie gesagt, die Diskussion um, ich geb einen Namen in eine Suchmaschine ein und lande da einige Dutzend Treffer oder einige tausend da, ist die eine Geschichte. Und die andere Seite ist halt wirklich, ich hab ganz arge Bedenken, wenn ich irgendwo ein Profil anlegen muss und dort eine Adresse oder eine E-Mail-Adresse eintragen muss oder eine Telefonnummer am besten oder wirklich eine reale Adresse oder sowas, da sträuben sie mir die Nackenhaare, weil ich hab immer so die Bedenken der großen böse Konzern, der dann seine Marketingmaschine rasseln lässt und nicht mehr die. Es gibt ja sicherlich solche Informationen, werden ja auf vielfältigste Art und Weise ausgewertet. Da halt ich, wie gesagt, dieses Foto-Analyt-Was-Säule ist ein guter Vergleich, weil ich überlege, wer wirklich denn seine Adresse irgendwo an der Was-Säule nageln würde.
Also ich glaube, wäre das früher problemlos finanzierbar gewesen, das zu tun, dann hätte das in gewisser Hinsicht auch stattgefunden. Aber es ist ja eher eine Frage des Kostenaufwandes, also allein Fotos zu reproduzieren in der Masse vergleicht sich nicht.
Ein Dienst namens Tagworld, der vergleichbar ist mit MySpace, ist mehr oder weniger das gleiche, ein bisschen netter gemacht, technisch gesehen. Die haben das sogar so gemacht, die haben quasi einen Profilwettbewerb stattfinden lassen und der Gewinner hat dann ein Billboard an der Autobahn gewonnen. Also konnte dann quasi sein Foto und seine Message und seinen Namen groß auf einem echten Plakat sehen. Also da ging es genau in die Richtung und da haben ganz viele Leute daran teilgenommen. Die Leute wollen ja gerne dieses Plakat.
Ja und die Frage ist halt immer noch, wenn ich selber an der Hand habe und das habe ich bei guten Services immer. Das heißt, wenn mich ein Service gleich beim ersten Mal oder beim fünften Mal nach der Telefonnummer fragt und mich nicht weitermachen lässt ohne die Telefonnummer, ohne dass ich die eingebe, dann muss ich mich sowieso sofort abmelden, das stimmt was nicht. Wenn ich es selbst in der Hand habe, kann ich natürlich auch positiv über mich selbst berichten und dafür sorgen, dass mein Bild im Webben gut ist.
Hm, ist halt die Frage, ob das, vielleicht hängt das unsicherlich mit der Persönlichkeit des Menschen zusammen, ob jemand auch gewillt ist, sich unbedingt so in die Öffentlichkeit zu stellen und so diesen Exhibitionismus auszuleben, der damit auch ein bisschen verbunden ist.
Ich sag nur Big Brother, also die Leute können ja gar nicht genug davon bekommen, ganz offensichtlich.
Ja, ich bin schon gruselig, ganz ehrlich.
Ja, aber da ist halt jeder auch anders.
Vor allem der Fernseh-Big Brother ist ein anderer als der George Orwell-Big Brother, wo eine Regierung alle Menschen beobachtet. Und beim jetzigen Big Brother beobachten viele ein Paar und im Internet beobachten alle alle.
Ja gut, aber es ist natürlich schon eine berechtigte Frage, dass diese Selbstdarstellung, wenn sie zum Beispiel ins Berufliche, ins Professionelle reingeht, also sicherlich viele, sehr viele sogenannte Headhunter oder auch Personalchefs fangen gerade im Bereich der Wissensarbeiter, wenn ich jetzt mal irgendwie bei einer Agentur Wissenschaft zum Beispiel unter Wissenschaftlern, da wird das schon mal gern gegoogelt, der Name. Und die Frage ist dann letzten Endes schon, wie lange kann ich es mir eigentlich leisten, mich da rauszuhalten und mich dort nicht zu publizieren und mich dort nicht darzustellen. Also es gibt sicherlich den Punkt, vor allem in bestimmten Bereichen, professionellen Bereichen, wo es anfängt, eben nicht nur diese freiwillige Fun-Selbstdarstellung zu sein, sondern wo dann irgendjemand sagt, ja Moment mal, der sagt, er hat alles das und das gemacht, das finde ich ja gar nicht bei Google. Also da gibt es gewisse Grenzen der Freiwilligkeit. Das ist eine Öffentlichkeit, der man sich sicherlich stellen muss, wenn man bestimmte Dinge tut.
Richtig, aber ich, also wie gesagt, wie gesagt, ich sehe mich jetzt persönlich nicht als Außenseiter, wenn ich solche Dienste nicht mag oder nicht unbedingt in Anspruch nehme. Wie gesagt, also Schätz und alles Mögliche, klar wird es genutzt, aber das sind dann auch wirklich meistens Leute, die ich schon vorher kannte. Wie gesagt, diese Verlagung des Freundeskreises ins Netz, ich halte es dann für höchstgefährlich, dass sowas auch dahin abdriftet, dass der reale Freundeskreis dann irgendwann verarmt und es wirklich bloß noch diese Netz...
Ich glaube, das kann man sozusagen bei den sehr jungen, klar so die Soziologie in dem Bereich, das ist ein sehr junges Feld, aber ich glaube, das kann man schon so ein bisschen widerlegen. Also es lässt sich nachweisen, es gibt kulturelle Unterschiede. Also die Amerikaner, die hängen mit ihren realen Freunden im Netz ab. Und zum Beispiel die Chinesen, die wollen vor allem ganz, ganz viele neue Freunde im Netz machen. Also ich weiß nicht, vielleicht hätte der eine oder andere schon mal die Erfahrung gemacht, dass bei Skype einen plötzlich irgendwelche wildfremden Chinesen anschetteln. Die Brasilianer sind da auch ganz groß. Also da gibt es kulturelle Unterschiede. In den USA, in Westeuropa ist es so, dass man eben nachweisen kann, dass die meisten mit ihrem realen Freundeskreis abhängen. Das heißt also nicht, dass man seine realen Freunde vernachlässigt deswegen. Die Frage, die sich natürlich stellt, ist, ist man irgendwann nicht mehr drin, wenn man da nicht mitspielt. Die Frage stellt sich schon, weil ich weiß ja nicht, wie es bei dir ist, zum Beispiel mit E-Mail. Das ist heutzutage dann schon fast, da wird man schon ein bisschen schräg angeguckt, wenn man keine E-Mail hat. Das gleiche gilt natürlich für Telefon. Da ist dann schon ein bisschen die Frage, wenn man nicht in irgendeiner Form eine digitale Identität hat, ob man dann überhaupt noch am sozialen Leben so in der Form teilnimmt. Das ist natürlich jetzt sehr provokant formuliert.
Ja, ich hab schon meine digitale Kommunikationsplattform, mehrere schon, die nutze ich auch. Aber wie gesagt, ich bin nicht so jemand, der nach Mittag, hm, lange Weile, was machen wir? Ach, setzen wir uns ein bisschen an den Rechner, chatten wir mit irgendjemandem. Dann doch nicht. Das finde ich so kurios, was man da für Energie reinstecken kann. Doch erst mal virtuelle, man sitzt halt nur erst mal vor dem Bild schon. Dass dann sicherlich jemand dahinter steckt, kommt ja erst danach.
Ja, so ist das. Es ist halt alles sehr divers. Und nicht alle machen das genauso, wie man das selbst macht.
Ja, aber die Frage ist natürlich, das hat Felix ja damit aufgeworfen. Also klar, E-Mail, da haben wir Konsens. Das braucht man schon, um halbwegs in der Gesellschaft anzukommen. Aber diese Grenze verschiebt sich ja immer weiter. Und was braucht man dann irgendwann?
Ich denke mal, das ist nichts. Dieses Brauchen wird nicht definiert durch irgendwelche Geschichten, dass man sagt, man kommt jetzt nicht weiter deswegen, sondern es hat eher wirklich was mit Anerkennung oder halt sozialen Geschichten zu tun.
Das sind gesellschaftliche Zwänge, ich weiß noch. 1995 hat man über Leute gelacht, die auf der Straße telefoniert haben.
Beziehungsweise man wurde voll geschimpft, wenn man es getan hat. Ja, ja, also alle fünf Jahre ändert sich das Paradigma an der Stelle. Ich meine, meine Aufgabe ist gerade, telefonlos zu werden. Ich finde, Telefon ist so eine Technologie des letzten Jahrtausends. Sonst muss ich jetzt mal ein Ende haben.
Sind Sie ehrlich, ja?
Ich muss sagen, ganz ehrlich, wenn ich irgendwie jetzt was kaufen möchte und es gibt von dem Händler, was auch immer, einen Online-Shop, greife ich doch lieber noch zum Telefon und telefoniere mit dem persönlich. Weil wenn ich dort irgendeinen Formular ausfüre und dem das hinschicke, dann habe ich erst mal keine Response. Da steht dann, ja, wir freuen uns über einen Auftrag, das wird bearbeitet, blabla. Da kommt doch vielleicht gleich eine E-Mail zurück. Aber wenn ich jemanden am Telefon habe, da höre ich auch sofort eine Reaktion. Dann hat er einen guten Tag, ist es auf Lager, schmilzt er mich an.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass ich nicht Kommunikation aufnehmen will. Ich will halt mit dem chatten. Ich will nicht immer mit den Leuten reden, weil da muss man immer sofort antworten und auch warten und da hängt man in Warteschleifen und ein bisschen Spracherkennungssystem, die irgendwelche Nummern von einem wollen. Das ist völlig sinnfrei.
Multitask lieber, ja.
Ja, ich weiß, es gibt jetzt schon so erste Online-Support. Da klickt man Ich will Support und dann wird man halt angechattet. Und das ist eigentlich, ja, ich finde das toll.
Okay, das ist das Ende dieser Sendung. Ehrlich gesagt, wenn er nicht mehr mit Leuten telefonieren möchte.
Genau, chatet uns doch an.
Nee, muss ich einräumen. Natürlich, hier ist es optimal. Natürlich hat Sprache seine Bedeutung. Aber mich nervt einfach das Telefon. In vielen Fällen, wo ich es früher vielleicht normal benutzt hätte. Ich denke, dass man auch das Telefon wiederum durch andere Technologien an vielen Stellen ersetzen kann. Und es etwas besseres dafür gibt. Das Telefon wird natürlich nicht aussterben, gar keine Frage. Aber ein paar andere Technologien müssen an die auch noch dran glauben.
Matthias, vielen Dank.
Viel Spaß noch bei der Sendung.
Danke schön.
Und vielleicht gibt es noch irgendwie so eine Zündende Idee, wo es mal hingehen wird. Web 3.0.
Es geht hier gleich weiter auch unter 033 71 97 110 gleich aber erst mal Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr.
Ist es denn wirklich so, dass wir jeden Dreck, der vom Westen kommt, nur kopieren müssen? Das je je je und wie das alles heißt.
Fritz präsentiert die Yeah Yeah Yes. Samstag, 27. Ab 19 Uhr im Fritz Club im Postbahnhof. Direkt am Berliner Ostbahnhof. Life in Berlin.
Mehr Infos fritz.de Jüüüü und im Radio Fritz, vom RBB.
0 Uhr 33.
Fritz Info.
Der Bundeskanzlerin Merkel und der russische Präsident Putin haben eine positive erste Bilanz ihrer Gespräche gezogen. Merkel sprach im Sibirischen Tombsk von einer breit angelegten strategischen Kooperation. Wirtschafts- und Energiethemen habe man bereits diskutiert. Unterschiedliche Standpunkte vertreten beide Länder im Atomstreit mit dem Iran und bei der Haltung gegenüber der Hamas geführten Palästinenser Regierung. Zehntausende Menschen in der Ukraine und vielen anderen Ländern haben der Reaktorkatastrophe von Tschernobyl vor 20 Jahren gedacht. In Schweigeminuten wurde an das Schicksal der Strahlenopfer erinnert. Auch in Deutschland fanden zahlreiche Gedenkveranstaltungen statt. US-Ausministerin Rice und Verteidigungsminister Rumsfeld sind überraschend nach Bagdad gereist. Mit dem Besuch wollen beide den designierten Ministerpräsidenten Al-Maliki unterstützen. Rumsfeld sprach in Bagdad über die langfristige amerikanische Militärpräsenz im Irak. Arbeitsverträge dürfen nicht allein wegen des Alters des Arbeitnehmers befristet werden. Mit dieser Entscheidung hat das Bundesarbeitsgericht eine zentrale Regelung der Arbeitsmarktreform Hartz IV für ungültig erklärt. Nach den Reformgesetzen durften Verträge ab einer Altersgrenze von 52 Jahren befristet werden. Dies Verstoße gegen den Gleichheitsgrundsatz, urteilte das Gericht. Der FC Barcelona steht zum zweiten Mal im Finale der Champions League. Ein 0-0 im Halbfinale-Rückspiel gegen den AC Milan reichte aus, da die Spanier bereits das Hinspiel gewonnen hatten. Gegner im Finale ist Arsenal London. Heute Nacht kann es noch kurze Schauer und Gewitter geben. Die Temperaturen sinken auf 11 bis 8 Grad. Tagsüber gibt es im Westen Brandenburg Schauer. Richtung Oder und Neiße bleibt es trocken. Die Temperaturen steigen auf 15 bis 20 Grad. Der Verkehr Fritz A10 östlicher Berliner Ring, Dreieck Spreeau Richtung Schwanebeck. Vorsicht bitte zwischen Berlin Hellersdorf und Berlin Marzahn. Hier könnten noch Hindernisse auf der Fahrbahn liegen. Und Stadt Autobahn Berlin A100 wedding Richtung Wilmersdorf. Die Autobahn ist zwischen Charlottenburg und Hohenzollern-Damm wegen Instandhaltungsarbeiten heute Nacht besperrt. Und zwar bis 5 Uhr morgen früh. Das war's, gute Fahrt ansonsten.
Und wenn im Radio 102, 6 dann Fritz in Berlin.
Ja, er ist dahinten richtig geil.
Geh ich mit meinen Kumpels in den Club, richtig geil.
Hab keine Kumpels, kein Club, ist auch richtig geil.
Bin ich morgens jut drauf, ist das richtig geil. Ha, Uhr ist scheiß, Laune ist das richtig geil. Jib, der Drüppel mit dem Müseseig, richtig geil.
Gibt korrekte Bratwurst, find ich richtig geil.
Korrekt, korrekt, ihr fällt mir jetzt ab.
Ihr fällt mir jetzt ab, ihr fällt mir so, ihr fällt mir so, wa? Ich und meine Homies, das ist richtig geil. Ich und keine Homies, das ist richtig geil. Haak Stress zu Hause, das ist richtig geil. Ist zu Hause alle in der Wolke, richtig geil. Ist Weihnachten und Ostern, das ist richtig geil.
Ist meine Mutti gut drauf, find ich das auch richtig geil.
Ich sag korrekt, korrekt, ihr fällt mal jeht ab. Ich sag korrekt, korrekt, ihr fällt mal jeht ab, jungs. Korrekt, korrekt, ihr fällt mal jeht ab.
Was war das um Gottes Willen?
Na ja, das ist halt so ein Lied, was auf MySpace rumliegt und da jetzt so gerade seine Hörer findet.
Ich sag nur korrekt, korrekt.
Ich find's richtig geil.
Noch 20 Minuten Chaosradio mit auch ungewöhnlicher Musik. Ihr könnt auch anrufen unter 033 71 97 110 und ich ahne schon wieder, wie es dann im Fritzbord nachher abgeht und Leute wissen wollen, dieser Song, den ich da gehört habe, wo bekomme ich den her?
Das steht natürlich alles auf unseren Webseiten in der Wiki-Seite, die Chaosradio immer begleitet. Ihr geht einfach mal auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Dort findet ihr den Link auf die aktuelle Sendung, Chaosradio 112. Und da wird das dann auch nachher auftauchen. Beziehungsweise auf der Wiki-Seite steht es wahrscheinlich jetzt schon, wie ich hier unsere Zuhörer kenne, die sind immer ganz fleißig im Nachtragen. Das ist übrigens auch der Ort, also chaosradio.ccc.de, wo ihr Chaosradio als Podcast abonnieren könnt, um die Sendung nochmal nachzuhören und auch um unsere sonstigen Angebote dazu genießen. Chaosradio Express, der das normale Chaosradio als Podcast noch begleitet. Und noch ein paar andere schöne Sachen, ChaosTV und so, das findet ihr alles dort. Und wenn euch das zu kompliziert ist, dann meinetwegen auch über iTunes abonnieren, gibt ja alle Möglichkeiten.
Und jetzt haben wir noch Anrufer. Emmi, 30 Jahre alt, aus Berlin, Prenzlauer Berg. Hallo, dann mal los.
Hallo, ich möchte mich ganz kurz fassen. Also ich habe explizit gar keine Frage zum Web 2.0. Da ich das Glück habe, mit einem ausgewiesenen Experten verheiratet zu sein, sodass ich viele Vorträge über das Web 2.0 auch ganz ungefragt bekomme. Und der sitzt jetzt auch bei euch im Studio, das ist Felix. Und ich möchte ihm gerne zum 30. Geburtstag gratulieren, den er jetzt gerade begonnen hat.
Das wusste ich ja noch gar nicht.
Dankeschön, seit 40 Minuten. Herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Danke, danke, danke, dass du angerufen hast.
Ja, ich lasse euch eure wertvolle Restzeit und wir sehen uns später.
Bis gleich.
Oh, und weg ist sie, gleich aufgelegt. Dann geht es jetzt weiter mit... Also, erst mal geht es weiter. Ich habe hier einen Moment gebraucht, aber das muss jetzt schon noch kurz sein.
Ist das falsch?
Gut, herzlichen Glückwunsch auch nochmal von mir. Und es geht jetzt weiter mit Mark, 19 Jahre alt, aus Cottbus.
Hallo, ich bin gerade mal im Bargeld-Internet gewesen bei mir. Ich bin über einen dummen Zufall, auf einer Seite gestolpert, über eine Seite gestolpert, nennt sich dayfriends.com.
Kannst du das nochmal sagen, wie hieß die?
dayfriends.com.
Vielleicht hab ich dir das was sagt.
Das sind die, die Google immer spamen und wenn ich irgendeinen Namen eingehe, will sie immer auf der ersten Seite auftauchen.
Ich hab mir so aus Spaß und Langeweile das Ding mal angeguckt und das beschäftige ich doch damit mit den Schulabgängern. Klickt man aber den Namen dieses Schulabgängers an, kriegt man von dem alle Daten, die man haben, der Geburtsdatum, wie gesagt Schule, kompletten Nebenverfahren, komplette Schulaufbahn, vielleicht gemeldete Adresse, Foto, alles, E-Mail-Adresse, Homepage, komplettes Vollprogramm.
Also ich kenne diesen Service nicht ganz genau, aber meiner Meinung nach, weil die halt eben, die geben die Leute quasi proaktiv ein. Das heißt, die nehmen sich Listen, irgendwelche Geburts, wie nennt man das?
Die Abgangslisten kriegen sie von den Schulen.
Genau, also die geben quasi Leute ein, bevor die sich selber dort angemeldet haben. Und dann findet man seinen eigenen Namen bei Google plötzlich wieder unter StealthFriends.de. Und dann wird man quasi gezwungen, lieber selber was über sich zu schreiben, weil man ist da ja eh schon drin. Also das ist sicherlich ein Vorgehen, was meiner Meinung nach nicht so in Ordnung ist. Ich bin aber auch nicht ganz sicher, ob es wirklich so läuft. Es ist halt sehr auffällig, dass da wirklich fast jeder Name drin ist.
Es ist fast jeder, sogar der von seinem Schuldirektor. Ich hab auch mal einen anderen Test gemacht. Ich hab meinen Namen auch mal bei Google eingegeben. Und da kamen dann auch auf eine Seite. Also die nennte sich dann www.marken-schattler.de, also sprich mein kompletter Name. Ich hab das Ding aber nie gebastelt. Und da waren dann auch plötzlich irgendwelche Bilder von mir zu finden.
Dann hast du Fans.
Kann nie sein. Das find ich dann auch schon mal komisch.
Also findest du das komisch oder hast dich erschrocken?
Ich hab mich richtig erschrocken. Das hab ich auch schon von mehr Leuten gehört. Wurden plötzlich irgendwie Seiten auftauchen. Da stand dann plötzlich ACQ-Nummer und alles mögliche mit da, wo... Ja, hallo, dachte ich, wo haben wir die Daten her?
Und das war unter... wo war das genau?
Das war unter... das war bei Google mit drin, wie es mit meinem kompletten Namen eingibt.
Ja, aber was war denn denn die Domain, unter der es lag?
eww.marken-schetter.de Was dein Name ist. Und ich habe dieses Ding aber nie gebastelt.
Da hat sich jemand die Mühe gemacht, einen Namen zu nehmen, die Domain zu registrieren und Informationen darüber einzustellen. Das ist sicherlich jemand, den du persönlich kennst, davon kann man ausgehen. Was halt manchmal auch vorkommt, ist, dass wenn ich mich bei Diensten anmelde, wie ICQ, wo man erstmal gar nicht denkt, dass es das überhaupt so im Web gibt, dann eben über die Angaben, die in dem Programm gemacht werden, gemacht habe, in dem Profil zum Beispiel, bei so einem Chatprogramm, Our Instant Messenger oder ICQ, dass das dann am Ende im Web in Verzeichnissen landet, in quasi so gelben, nicht gelbe Seiten, sondern weiße Seiten, White Pages, wo dann alle User auch nochmal gelistet sind und die Informationen, die du woanders über dich preisgegeben hast, dort auch nochmal auftauchen. Das ist sicherlich auch eine problematische Praxis, weil nur weil ich mich bei ICQ anmelde, ich nicht unbedingt das Ganze für Google veröffentlichen möchte.
Du könntest ja mal nachgucken, wer die Domain registriert hat.
Da kam gerade ein wichtiger Hinweis, du könntest mal nachgucken, wer die Domain registriert hat.
Ja, genau.
Ich weiß bei dir nicht, wie wir es morgen früh machen.
Genau, das würde ich mal tun, und dann kannst du ja rausfinden, wer das war.
Selbst bei dir nicht kann man dir das Obsedonymnamen anmelden.
Nein, nicht dass ich wüsste.
Das hält dann aber nicht lange.
Ich schätze, wenn die Seite so ist, bin ich so lange drinne.
Welche Seite?
Das ist meine jetzt, die eigentlich nicht meine ist.
Ja, du bist wahrscheinlich einfach zu prominent.
Man, wer wir jetzt nicht klären können, zudem neigt sich die Sendung dem Ende und wir haben auch noch einen Anrufer mindestens.
Genau.
Dann dir eine gute Nacht. Danke für deinen Anruf. Volker ist 25 Jahre alt und ruft aus Düsseldorf an. Hallo Volker.
Ja, hallo. Ich wollte mal fragen, inwiefern so Online-Rollenspiel-Communities und so was mittlerweile auch zu Web 2.0 gerechnet werden können. Weil jetzt was Neues, das geht ja dahin, dass man Werbung auch einblendet in Spiele und von den ganzen Spielefirmen auch für die Communities so Kaufhäuser. Also es gibt ja bei diesem World of Warcraft irgendwie diese Leute, die da Gold farmen und so was verkaufen.
Also es ist mit Sicherheit ein Phänomen, was vielleicht ein bisschen parallel zu der ganzen Web 2.0-Geschichte im Moment ein sehr, sehr großes Thema ist. Du hast es angesprochen, World of Warcraft, da gibt es noch ein paar andere. Da gibt es zum Beispiel auch was ich sehr interessant finde, Second Life, was sicherlich so einen weiteren Evolutionsschritt darstellt. Es gibt Leute, die so weit gehen zu sagen, das wäre quasi Web 3.0. Deswegen ist es auch eine sehr schöne Frage zum Abschluss. Eine Sache ist sicherlich die, diese Spiele haben durch die soziale Komponente, man hat eigentlich in der ganzen Geschichte Spiele nie alleine gespielt. Das war eine ganz kurze Phase in der Geschichte, wo die Leute in ihren Computern Spiele alleine gespielt haben. Was an Spielen wirklich Spaß macht, ist sie zusammen zu spielen. Ein Erfolg von Spielen wie World of Warcraft ist die soziale Komponente, die weit über das eigentliche Spielen, also sich gegenseitig töten oder irgendwelche Orks abmurksen, hinausgeht, sondern die Leute treffen sich da inzwischen. Es gibt schon Leute, die sagen, World of Warcraft ist das Golf für Nerds. Und es gibt sogar schon Berichte, dass da auch schon Deals und Geschäftspartner sich treffen und Deals gemacht werden. Second Life ist insofern ganz interessant, weil diese ganzen Plattformen, die werden ja bisher von einzelnen Firmen kontrolliert. Und das ist eben nicht das, was das Web ausmacht. Das heißt, es gibt eine Firma und alles, was ich dort tue, gehört dieser Firma. Und wenn ich zum Beispiel meine Schwerte bei Ebay versteige, dann darf ich das so eigentlich gar nicht. Second Life ist einen Schritt weiter gegangen. Die haben gesagt, alles, was du bei uns kreierst, gehört auch dir. Und außerdem haben sie quasi so eine Art Wirtschaft eingeführt. Das heißt, ich kann also Geld, reales Geld gegen Geld in Second Life tauschen. Kann damit Dinge erwirtschaften, kann Geld verdienen und kann dieses reale Geld sogar wieder zurücktauschen. Und es gibt diese eine chinesische Studentin in Deutschland, glaube ich, oder Chinesin zumindest, die davon lebt und die davon recht gut lebt. Also die macht Immobilien, Entwicklungsprojekte in Second Life. Second Life ist dann schon gar nicht mehr so ein Spiel, wo es um ein Ziel geht, wie sich gegenseitig abzumurksen, sondern da geht es... es ist im Endeffekt eine 3D-Welt. Eine komplett eigene 3D-Welt, die ich vor allem auch skripten und programmieren kann. Das heißt, ich kann Dinge dort kreieren. Und um es kurz zu machen, meiner Meinung nach viele Elemente von Second Life haben Ähnlichkeit mit den frühen, mit sowas wie CompuServe oder AOL, was schon kontrollierte Plattformen sind, die aber auch eine gewisse Freiheit erlauben. Das heißt, ich kann dort Dinge tun, ich kann kreativ sein und ich kann damit am Ende sogar Geld verdienen. Es hat natürlich ein völlig anderes Interface. Es ist 3D, aber ich kann auch so Sachen wie Streams und Websites dort wieder reinpacken. Das heißt, es ist sogar ein Layer, quasi eine Schicht über dem Web. Und es ist schon sehr interessant. Also das ist sicherlich sehr spannend, was da passiert und wo das hingeht. Und so wie ich das gehört habe, wird Second Life das auch dezentralisieren. Das heißt, sie haben nicht mehr einen Server, sondern ich kann quasi meinen eigenen Second Life Server dann betreiben. Und das ist eigentlich nur noch ein Protokoll.
Ist das eine Vermutung oder ist das eine Ankündigung?
Das ist eine Ankündigung, die ich bei der eTek aufgeschnappt habe von jemandem von Linden Labs, also der Firma, der dahintersteckt.
Oh, das ist ja interessant.
Das ist praktisch mein eigenes Stück Land, ob man auf eigenen Server betreiben.
Es ist jetzt schon so, wenn ich ein Stück Land kaufe, wird da quasi ein eigener, dezidierter Server für mich rangezogen.
Und die Welt, die da gebaut wird, die ist auch schon echt groß. Ich glaube, vor kurzem hatte ich einen Vergleich gehört, also virtuell, das hat ja so eine Ausdehnung. Also man baut da halt tatsächlich, man kann da Häuser bauen, man kann da irgendwie Fläche akquirieren und das wird natürlich dann auch mit denselben Maßen angegeben. Und ich glaube, die bebaute Fläche und ausgebaute Fläche ist schon so groß wie New York, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe. Also da tut sich was.
New York ist ja nicht so groß.
Ich muss bedenken, jeder, der dort ein Stück Land kauft, der bezahlt echtes Geld dafür. Also es ist nicht so, dass ich mich da einfach mal anmelde, sondern ich kann mich umsonst anmelden und mitmachen und darum laufen. Aber wenn ich Land kaufe, das geht bis hin zur eigenen Insel. Die kostet dann glaube ich bis zu 16.000 US-Dollar.
Ich rede von New York, nicht von New York City. Aber ich kann auch ein bisschen falsch liegen, aber nicht sehr. Na vielleicht auch sehr, aber ich glaube nicht.
Also es ist schon groß.
Volker, bist du mit dem Gesprächsverlauf zufrieden?
Aber eins finde ich noch an Web 2.0 eigentlich schade, dass so bei den ganzen Diensten, die neu aufkommen oder neu aufgekommen sind, so ICQ und ja gut, Java ist ganz interessant. Einige Sachen auch in Vergessenheit geraten, wie zum Beispiel IRC und sowas.
Ja, die Dienste, die du gerade aufgezählt hast, finde ich sind nicht unbedingt Web 2.0. Ich meine, IRC gibt es ja schon ein paar Jahre.
Ja, IRC gerät durch so Sachen wie ICQ und sowas auch in Vergessenheit. Also benutzen nicht mehr viele Leute, die jetzt gerade ans Internet rangeführt werden.
Ja, aber der Chaosradio-Chat ist voll.
Ja, das kann man wohl sagen.
Ja, und da würde jetzt auch ICQ nicht helfen. Also das ist ja das Ding. Diese ganzen Dienste gehen nicht wirklich weg. Sogar das Usenet gibt es ja noch, auch wenn es derzeit mehr zum Wares-Trading benutzt wird als für irgendwas anderes. Aber gut, ich meine, IRC, also dieser Internet-Chat, der war halt für eine bestimmte Anwendung von Kommunikationen gebaut. Und genau diesen Bedarf deckt er ja noch ab. Da hat er ja auch keine Konkurrenz. Also ich meine, wenn man das machen will, was man mit IRC gut machen kann, dann nimmt man halt IRC. Oder? Hab ich irgendwas übersehen?
Nö, also da kann man schöne Sachen mitmachen. Da kann man einen Server drauf aufsetzen, also Dateiserver.
Ja, und lässt sich halt auch gut kombinieren. Also das passt schon.
Danke Volker. Ich hab noch eine Mail von Matt bekommen, oder Matt, aber ich nehme mal einen Matt. Der schreibt, was man jetzt zum Abschluss vielleicht ganz gut machen könnte, dass er eigentlich Paul van Dyck gehört hat, dann in der Diskussion hängen geblieben ist und das alles sehr spannend fand. Was mich speziell noch interessieren würde, ist der Punkt, was wünscht man sich als User gerade in Bezug auf Web 2.0 heutzutage noch? Welche Alternativen gäbe es für Unternehmen, Informationen bereitzustellen? Fest steht, dass statische Informationen wie bei Zeitungen oder Ähnlichem mittlerweile unerwünscht sind. Also ich meine, diesen Ausblick könnte man jetzt zum Abschluss...
Also es gibt eine Web 2.0 Anwendung, die fehlt schon seit 15 Jahren. Und ich bin nach wie vor entsetzt, dass es da einfach keine ordentliche Lösung gibt. Und ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wer da mauert, aber irgendjemand hat da was noch nicht verstanden. Es gibt einfach bis zum heutigen Tage, und es ist eigentlich die erste Anwendung, die ich schon immer, eine der ersten Anwendungen, die es überhaupt gab im Internet. Und eine, die alle Nerds haben wollen, die eigentlich auch sonst alle haben wollen. Aber es gibt bis zum heutigen Tage keine gute Kinoauskunft. Es ist einfach verdammt nochmal nicht möglich, in diesem Internet rauszufinden, was läuft jetzt, was mich interessiert hier um die Ecke. Also falls irgendjemand von euch jetzt neu in die Economy einsteigen will, bitte, ich zahle sogar Geld dafür. Also es ist unglaublich, dass sich da noch nichts getan hat. Ich meine, ich weiß woran es liegt, es hat auch ein bisschen was mit dem Kinoverband zu tun. Die tun die Daten hier raus, die verstehen das irgendwie nicht, weiß nicht, sind da irgendwie blockiert oder es gibt da irgendeine Firma, die hat die Finger da drauf. Es ist ein Drama. Alles, was man heutzutage im Web kriegt, ist einfach ein Rotz. Anstatt dass sie einfach mal sagen, wir sammeln die Daten mal ordentlich ein, machen da mal ein Datenformat und dann liegen die Daten einfach auf Server XY, Kinoverband.de oder keine Ahnung, wie das heißt und dann geht's los. So einfach kann man eine Industrie gründen.
Absurd, da ist der Videotext immer noch besser als das Netz, zumindest in diesem Punkt. Das ist wirklich eine absurde Vorstellung.
Es gibt immerhin in Schweden eine sehr interessante Anwendung, die heißt glaube ich Filmtipser.se für alle, die Schwedisch können, können sich jetzt auch gerufen fühlen, sich mal anzugucken, die durch recht gute Collaborative Filtering Mechanismen einem zumindest die zwei Filme sagt, in die man auf jeden Fall gehen muss und die nächsten drei, in die man gehen könnte, wenn man denn unbedingt ins Kino muss und die 65, die man sich auf gar keinen Fall ansehen muss. Das haben sie jetzt aufs Fernsehen ausgebreitet und das ist sehr schick.
Aber das Kino um die Ecke fehlt dann noch.
Das fehlt noch, ja.
Ja, aber die Filmindustrie, Musikindustrie ist ja eh dafür bekannt, irgendwie ein Brett vorm Kopf zu haben. Die haben ja Angst vor dem Internet, die haben ja noch nicht verstanden, dass es ihr Freund ist, was sehr schade ist.
Also eine Sache fällt mir persönlich und ich weiß nicht, ob das vielen Leuten bewusst ist, aber es gibt keinen Dienst, der zentral meine Identität verwaltet. Also in jedem System habe ich einen Account, einen eigenen Login, muss mir 150.000 Passwörter merken, muss jedes Mal aufpassen, wem ich wann wo meine Daten schicke und was wir bräuchten, wäre eigentlich ein zentraler Dienst, der meine Identität verwaltet. Das Problem ist, wer macht das? Macht das Microsoft? Nee, macht das Google?
Und wem vertraust du dann?
Microsoft hat das ja schon probiert mit Passport.
Die Vereinten Nationen sollten es vielleicht machen.
Im Endeffekt muss es was sein, was du wirklich selber konsumierst.
Ich will das selber tun. Wie in DNS ich meine eigene Domain und meinen eigenen Webserver mache, würde ich natürlich auch meine eigene Identitätsverwaltung betreiben und auf Anfrage verschlüsseln mit Cryptografie und Fubar. Das bereitstellen, wenn es jemand unbedingt wissen will oder wenn ich es jemand anderem gegenüber beweisen möchte. Das ist sicherlich technisch machbar, aber derzeit ist es natürlich auch noch ein Kampf um die Identität, weil das ist natürlich auch der Schlüssel für den Markt von morgen. Google und die anderen Großen haben den Vorteil, dass sie so eine große Userbase haben, dass sie einfach erst mal drauf scheißen können, weil die haben das sozusagen in ihrem System drin und es reicht für sie. Aber da ist auf jeden Fall noch was zu holen. Da gibt es ja auch diverse Projekte. Ich weiß nicht, ich habe dich damit ja schon mal ein bisschen beschäftigt. Gibt es da irgendeinen verheißungsvollen Ansatz oder sind die alle bloß?
Es gibt sxip.com in den USA. Die probieren das aber auch schon seit Jahren. Und kommen jedes Jahr mit irgendeinem neuen Konzept raus. Also ich glaube, das Problem ist einfach, dass es eine Technologie sein müsste, die jeder selber steuern kann und die genauso offen ist wie das Web, wie die Protokolle und die Technologien, die man da nutzt. Und dass nie eine größere Menge von Menschen ihre Daten einfach oder ihre Identität, das ist ja nicht nur irgendwie ein Teil meiner Identität, meine E-Mail-Adresse, sondern meine ganze Identität, irgend jemandem an Vertrauen.
Es ist wie End-to-End-Verschlüsselung, die letzten Endes auch bisher daran gescheitert ist, dass sie nicht wirklich gut zu benutzen ist. Das ist eine schwierige Geschichte, aber es wäre mit Sicherheit anstrebenswert. Also das ist eine Nuss, wer die knackt, der hat sicherlich viel gewonnen. Allein schon die Tatsache, dass ich dann irgendwie eine Liste von Diensten hab, durch die ich durchgehen kann und sagen kann, der darf nicht mehr, der darf nicht mehr, den mag ich auch nicht mehr und die anderen sind okay. Im Moment glaubt man sich das ja auch aus seinen E-Mails zusammen. Ich hab da irgendwie so einen Ordner, der heißt Receipts and Passes oder irgendwie sowas und da guckt man dann ab und zu durch.
Wir sind am Ende angekommen, also Tim kennt dieses Problem, Stefan und Felix lernen es gerade kennen. Um 1 Uhr fällt hier definitiv der Hammer. Vielen Dank und das Schlusswort würde ich gerne euch dann überlassen, Felix, sogar dem Geburtstagskind.
Och, ich weiß nicht, jetzt haben wir auch schon wirklich alles gesagt. Also, naja, ich kann vielleicht nochmal sagen, Web 2.0 tut nicht weh. Und es gibt da draußen eine ganze Menge Dienste, die sind es durchaus wert, mal ausprobiert zu werden. Wenn ihr selber Entwickler seid, probiert doch mal was aus. Und wenn ihr euch irgendwie an dieses Thema rantastet und ihr werdet mit den ersten Formularen konfrontiert, wo ihr mal wieder eure Daten angeben sollt, dann haltet das erstmal so pseudonym, wie ihr es für angemessen haltet. Anonymität im Internet gibt es nicht. Aber zumindest eine Tarnnamen-Methodik ist angemessen, wenn man eben nicht so richtig weiß, was sich jetzt hinter diesem Dienst wieder versteckt. Und wenn man das lange genug ausprobiert hat, dann weiß man vielleicht schon besser, woran es ist. Auf jeden Fall sollte man seine Experimentierfreude nicht einbüßen und immer schön nach vorne schauen.
Mein Schlusswort, ich meine, Tim hat ja alles gesagt, was man dazu sagen kann. Meins wäre nochmal der Aufruf, wenn ihr was machen wollt, wenn ihr Lust habt, was zu machen, guckt euch das an. Es war noch nie so einfach, wie heute, was im Web zu machen.
Ja, gut, dem kann ich mich auch nur anschließen. Macht was draus. Das Web war sicherlich noch nie so interessant, wie es jetzt ist. Und es wird noch spannender.
Vielen Dank euch dreien. Hier geht es gleich weiter mit dem Night Flight und Martin Petersdorf. Das nächste Chaosradio gibt es, wenn nichts dazwischen kommt, am letzten Mittwoch im Mai. Das ist der...
Letzte Mittwoch im Mai.
Der letzte Mittwoch im Mai.
Mal nachgucken. Aber das werdet ihr sicherlich schon selber rauskriegen können.
Gute Calendar-Applikation.
Ja, das ist dann der 31.
Der 31. Mai, dann das nächste Chaosradio. Das ist dann Folge 113, wenn ich richtig informiert bin.
Du bist richtig informiert.
Ok, dann euch einen schönen Abend und viel Spaß im Nightclub.